Rồi các bạn
cái buổi gần đấy nhất chúng ta học chúng
ta đã bắt đầu chúng ta chuyển phần code
rồi đúng không? Chúng ta chúng ta mới
làm cái việc là chúng ta mở cái file ra
và chúng ta dùng một cái thư viện tên là
e data profiling này để chúng ta export
ra một cái file report dạng HTML. Đây
file như này. Mở lại nhá. Mở lại nhá.
Nhắc lại tí này. Bạn nào quên này.
Đâ chờ mình một xíu.
Đây chúng ta có một cái file đây. Cái
file diabetes report này đúng không? Cái
file report ta mở ra nhá. Mở ra nhá. Như
này
đâu rồi?
Đây mở report ra chấm như thế này này.
Đấy đúng không? Cái report mình nó như
thế này đúng không? Mình nhìn những cái
thông tin tổng quát về cái bộ rượu của
mình nó đây đúng không? Từng các bạn
chọn từng cái cột một này thấy chưa?
Đúng không? Chúng ta xem là à chúng ta
xem là
ví dụ có một vài như là cái
cái gì nhỉ? Coration magic đúng không?
Cái coration magic như này. Coration
magic như thế này đúng không? Có một vài
ô nó bị vài ô không ô nào bị khuyết cả
đúng không? Tức là 768 này bộ diện mình
cũng chỉ 768 thôi đúng không? Không ô
nào bị khuyết cả đúng không? Một vài xem
đầu một vài xem m cuối đúng không? Muốn
xem cái histogram nó thì vào đây đây
detail đây vào đây được chưa? Metail ở
đây được chưa? Histogram trông như này
được chưa? Đấy
và các bạn có nhớ là hôm nọ mình có để ý
là chúng ta có cái coration magic này
đúng không? Chúng ta nhìn vào cái cor
magic này. Hôm n chúng ta có một cái
nhận xét là gì các bạn nhỉ?
Nhìn vào cái coration magic này. Hôm nọ
cái hôm cuối cùng chúng ta học ấy, chúng
ta có một cái nhận xét là gì ấy nhỉ?
Nhận xét gì đây? Số đây. Cái cột chúng
ta cần phải dự đoán là cái là cái cột
outcome này. Outcome này cột chúng ta
cần phải dự đoán này. Chúng ta có nhận
xét gì nhỉ? Nhìn vào cái hàng cái hàng
của cái outcome này hoặc là cái cột của
outcome này. Các bạn thấy là có nhận xét
gì các bạn?
Nhận xét gì?
Feature càng liên quan tới cái càng tốt
nhưng mà các feature càng liên quan đến
nhau. Không cái đấy không cái đấy cái
đấy là cái trước rồi cái đấy là cái
chung chung rồi còn đây là cụ thể với
cái bộ rượu này cơ. Đấy là cái chung
chung tức là gì? Nếu mà một hoặc là một
vài những cái feature có cái hệ số tương
quan lớn với target là cái điểm mà chúng
ta mong muốn. Còn giữa các cái feature
có cái hệ số tương quan lớn với nhau là
điều chúng ta không mong muốn. Thì đấy
là cái tổng quát rồi. Nhưng mà cụ thể
cái bài này cơ. Ui giời cái bài này cho
nận chúng ta có nhận nhận xét gì các
bạn?
Ô nhỉ có hai tuần không gặp nhau n lại
chả thấy hết rồi.
Nhận thì là chú nhận xem là cái bộ dượ
này nó làm sao các bạn ạ? Bộ rượu này nó
làm sao? Cái bộ rượu này nó làm sao?
Tất cả những cái nó in ra này. Tất cả
những cái các bạn in ra nó đều có một
cái ý nghĩa gì đấy đúng không? Chứ không
phải người ta in ra cho vui đúng không?
Nhưng cái này nó sẽ giúp chúng ta làm
cái điều gì đó. Thế cụ thể với cái
coration magic này nó giúp chúng ta tìm
cái gì
đấy như này
mà thấy là cái bộ rượu này không có cái
feature nào có cái hệ số tương quan lớn
với tit hệ số tương quan lớn tức là gần
1 hoặc là gần -1 đúng không?
Chúng nói rồi mà các bạn trước cái buổi
học trước chúng ta nói rồi mà đúng không
các bạn? Nhìn đây đúng không? Làm gì có
ông nào có cái hệ số tương quan lớn với
cả Tit đâu. Có nghĩa là gì? Nếu mà một
cái bộ dữ liệu mà chẳng có cái feature
nào có cái hệ số tương quan lớn với TX
cả thì làm sao?
Thì sao?
À thì con nên dùng mô hình phi tuyến
đúng không? Tại vì là mô hình tuyến tính
nó sẽ chỉ phù hợp khi mà chúng ta có
những cái bộ dữ liệu có cái hệ số tương
quan lớn giữa giữa feature với tit thôi.
Bộ này nó chả có ông nào có như thế cả
đúng không? Thì tôi sẽ dùng những mô
hình nên dùng mô hình phi tuyến đúng
không? Tí nữa khi mình code mình sẽ dùng
mô hình phi tuyến được chưa? Thế rồi ok
đấy là một điểm đúng không? Thế thì bạo
ba sẽ đúng không? Nhìn qua thì cũng dự
toàn là dạng số cả đúng không? Tất cả
đều dạng số đây. Tất cả những cô đều là
dạng dạng số cả đúng không? Xem một vài
hàng 10 hàng đầu 10 hàng cuối đây đúng
không? Nhìn qua đ cũng chưa có gì bất
bình thường cả đúng không? Cái a căm nó
chỉ có hai giá trị thôi. Không là khỏe
mạnh, không là không bị làm sao cả và
một là người ta bị tiểu đường đúng. Một
là bị tiểu đường, không là không bị
không bị làm sao cả.
Đấy, thì vậy thôi lại quay lại về code
lại code nhìn thấy là đủ rồi, không quay
lại về code đây. Đúng không? Thì cái đợi
mà chúng ta export vậy chúng ta chỉ chạy
một lần thôi đúng không? Chúng ta có cái
report rồi là ok rồi. Được chưa? Rồi
thầy quay lại ở đây cái chúng ta như thế
này đúng không? Và mình nói lại nhắc lại
là gì? là các bạn mà muốn mở cái file dữ
liệu ngay trong cái ID ví dụ đây mình
dùng P chẳng hạn có nhiều cách lắm ví dụ
đây các bạn mở đây các bạn nhầm nhầm
nhầm nhầm bộ nhầm bộ đây các bạn cái bộ
DBT đây chưa mở như này thấy chưa mở này
nhìn nó hơi xấu một tí cách mình làm thì
mình hay làm là mình sẽ bôi đen hết lại
này bôi đen hết cái đoạn script này đúng
không bôi đen hết này do cái ở cái vùng
màu xanh này chỗ nào cũng được mình
click chuột phải một cái này click chuột
phải một cái này đúng không chọn các bạn
chọn cái dòng là execute
Selection in Python console. Click vào
đấy hoặc là phím tắt là add shift với e
này. Click vào đây chưa? Chờ một tí. Chờ
một tí xong thì ở góc dưới cung bên phải
nó sẽ hiện ra một cái bảng
góp dung cù bên phải nó t bảng như này.
Đấy chưa? Bảng như này chưa? Click vào
cái views data frame này. Được chưa? V
interfame này. Đấy mình mình hay xem
kiểu này. Hay xem kiểu này. Xem nó kéo
ra kéo vàng nó rất là linh động. Nó tự
động nó resign cho mình. Và mình sẽ nhìn
thấy những cái màu của những cột này
mình biết là có cái giá trị nào nó đột
biến không? To đột biến hoặc là nhỏ đột
biến. Đấy nhìn những cột này được chưa?
Mình thì mình hay xem kiểu như này. Đấy
cái thường ngày xưa cái đ cái đây khoảng
2 3 năm cái phiên bản 300 cũ ấy nó theo
màu là kiểu màu xanh với màu đỏ. Càng
gần xanh thì càng bé, càng gần đỏ thì
càng lớn. Mà bây giờ thì nó đổi theo
kiểu là càng gần đen thì càng bé mà càng
gần tím thì càng lớn. Được chưa? Rồi các
bạn thế bây giờ đọc dữ liệu rồi đúng
không? Được chưa? Thì theo các bạn bây
giờ chúng ta xem report rồi, chúng ta
đọc dữ liệu rồi. Theo các bạn cái bước
tiếp theo mà chúng ta cần làm chúng ta
làm cái gì? À một cái nữa nhá ngày xưa
ấy hồi mà chưa có cái report này ấy là
mình phải in ra rất rất rất nhiều thứ.
Ví dụ mình in ra này, ví dụ in này, đúng
không?
data [âm nhạc]
ta chấm chấm head này head là để xem một
vài hàng nhá đúng không vài hàng này cho
bạn xem khoảng năm hàng đầu tiên đây năm
hàng đầu tiên đúng không head này được
chưa và các bạn dùng cái hàm của hàm
info
này
đây như này info nó cho các bạn là mỗi
ông cột được kiểu gì đấy đây chưa đấy
sau đó các bạn dùng hàm describe
describe này describe đây như này đúng
không đấy tức là ngày xưa bọn mình phải
dùng rất nhiều những cái hàm thủ công
này. Mỗi hàm lại cho các bạn xem một vài
thứ sau lại ngồi vẽ vời các thứ nữa rất
là phải làm rất là nhiều thứ khác nhau
nhưng mà bây giờ các bạn có một cái
report này là một phát là xong không
phải không phải in ra nhiều thứ tủn mủn
riêng lẻ nữa được chưa? Rồi thì câu hỏi
này sau khi sau khi đọc dữ liệu vào rồi
theo các bạn bước tiếp theo chúng ta cần
làm cái gì?
Sau khi đọc dữ liệu vào rồi, bước tiếp
theo chúng ta cần làm cái gì?
Làm cái gì bây giờ?
Ừ, sử dụng đúng nhưng mà hơi chung chung
nhỉ. Sử dụ nó có nhiều thứ lắm. Lọc vẫn
hơi chung chung. Lọc là lọc cái gì? Xử
lý xử lý cái gì? Tiền xử lý vẫn hơi
chung chung. Vẫn hơi chung chung. Tiền
xử lý có nhiều thứ lắm. Làm cái gì bây
giờ? Cụ thể đi, một cái việc cụ thể mình
có thể ngồi gõ code. Tiền xử lý thì
nhiều lắm.
Cụ thể mình làm cái gì bây giờ?
Phiền giá trị bị rỗng á. Thật ra thì vẫy
đúng bình thường là chúng ta sẽ phải
ngồi chúng ta điền vào chỗ bị khuyết.
Nhưng mà vậy các bạn nhớ là chúng ta mở
report ra cho thấy là diện ra nó không
nào nó bị khuyết cả. Đúng không? Đây
này. Hoặc vậy mình dùng cái hàm info á.
Đây này các bạn dùng cái hàm info nhá.
Đây này. Nó chỉ ra là không ô nào bị
khuyết cả. Đây này. Đấy 768 này không ôm
nào bị khuyết cả. Đều như mơ luôn đúng
không?
Đúng chọn target chính xác phải chọn
target đúng không? Chọn tagit mình đã
chọn đâu đúng không? Tagit là cái cột
outcome này đúng nhưng mà mình đã chọn
đâu đúng không? Với cái bộ này mình có
thể chọn outcome là tagit mình cũng có
thể chọn bất kỳ một cột nào là tit cả
đúng không? Chúng ta chọn outcome thì nó
là bài toán classification. Các bạn chọn
cái cột các ví dụ các bạn chọn cái này
hay bằng bài toán regression ngay đúng
không? Mình sẽ chọn cái cột outcome
đúng. Ok. Chọn tit nào. Tit
bằng time. Chính xác. Rồi chọnit xong
làm gì tiếp?
[âm nhạc]
Chọn tit xong làm gì tiếp bây giờ? Đúng
rồi.
Làm gì tiếp đây?
Tí rồi.
Làm gì tiếp?
À chính xác. Một cái bước mà rất nhiều
người ta hay bỏ qua đó là đó là đó là đó
là chia đúng rồi chia thành bộ chuyên bộ
test đúng chia thành bộ chuyên bộ test
tại vì đây là dữ liệu bạn nó là một cục
đúng không nó là một cục mà các bạn nhớ
cái hôm chúng ta học chúng ta nói rồi
chúng ta thường chúng ta sẽ phải chia
làm ba bộ train
validation và test đúng không hoặc người
ta có thể chia thành kiểu là keyf cross
variation tức là trin với test đúng
không sau đó thì chúng ta dùng kf chúng
sẽ có trin với va sau đúng không tức là
trí là phải chia ra làm hai bộ là trên
với test đúng chia thành bộ chuyên với
bộ test. Nhưng trước khi muốn chia thành
bộ chuyên và bộ test, chúng ta vẫn có
một cái thứ nữa chúng ta phải làm trước
gì nhỉ?
Là chúng ta gán cái
thống kê thống kê mình vừa làm vừa nãy
rồi đấy. Thống kê được nãy làm rồi đấy
đúng không? Vậy chúng ta dùng cái report
là nó bao gồm cả thống kê cả chữ c nói
trong đấy hết rồi đấy.
Chúng a chúng ta sẽ phải làm việc là gì?
Chúng ta sẽ phải tách ra là
input xong một bên và output y sang một
bên. Đúng không? Chúng ta có cột tit
này. Rồi các bạn bỏ cái cột này đi. Bỏ
cột t đi thì các bạn có x. Các bạn chỉ
giữ tit thì các bạn có y đúng không? Đấy
thì chúng ta phải làm cái đấy trước xong
chúng ta mới phân chia làm trên bộ trên
bộ test sau. Được chưa? Tách thì rất là
dễ. Tách thì rất là dễ. Ví dụ chúng ta
các bạn nhìn nhá. Trong PAS mình có một
cái hàm gọi là hàm drop. Đây này đây này
chưa tắt AI nó như này này đây các bạn
nhìn này đây được chưa nó có một hàm gọi
là hàm drop cái hàm này dùng để bỏ hàng
hoặc là bỏ cột nhá hàng drop này nếu mà
các bạn chưa dùng bao giờ nháas này drop
nhá cái hàm
cái hàm
cái hàm cái hàm drop này nhá cái hàm này
thật ta gọi là gọi là hàm thì gọi Bạn
hàm thì không đúng, nó gọi là phương
thức mới đúng. Đúng không? Nó nó đi theo
lớp mà nó đi theo lớp. Cái phương thức
này ấy nó giúp các bạn có thể loại bỏ
một vài hàng hoặc một vài cột. Các bạn
sẽ chỉ ra các bạn muốn loại bỏ cái gì.
Thế thì dùng cái này thì nó sẽ có hai
thứ các bạn cần phải để ý. Một là cái
label. Label các bạn hiểu cái nó chính
là cái tên. Nó là cái tên của cái hàng
hoặc là tên của cái cột mà các bạn muốn
bỏ. Được chưa? Nó là tên của hàng hoặc
tên của cột mà chúng ta muốn bỏ. Thế ví
dụ nếu mà các bạn muốn bỏ cột thì các
bạn sẽ phải chỉ ra là cái cột các bạn
tên nó là gì. Ví dụ đây mình muốn bỏ cột
chứ gì thì mình sẽ phải chỉ ra là mình
muốn bỏ cái cột là skin thchnis hay là
insulin hay là BMI chẳng hạn. Ví dụ như
vậy. Thế còn nếu muốn bỏ hàng ấy, nếu bỏ
cột thì dựa theo tên, còn bỏ hàng thì
dựa theo chỉ số. Đây này. 1 2 này các
bạn nhìn 1 2 3 4 này. Đúng không? Muốn
bỏ cột thì phải chỉ ra tên của cột. Muốn
bỏ hàng thì phải chỉ ra cái index của
cái hàng. Được chưa? Đấy. Thế các bạn
nhìn đây này. Đây này. Label này đúng
không? nó là index nếu mà bỏ theo hàng
hoặc nó là con label nếu mà bỏ theo cột.
Được chưa? Các bạn phải chỉ ra. Đấy là
cái thứ nhất. Cái thứ hai nữa là gì? Các
bạn phải chỉ ra là các bạn muốn bỏ theo
cái trục gì? Các bạn muốn bỏ hàng thì
các bạn sẽ chỉ ra số 0 đây này. Còn nếu
mà các bạn muốn bỏ cột các bạn chỉ ra số
1. Các bạn mà không chỉ ra cái gì nó sẽ
mặc định là các bạn muốn muốn bỏ theo
hàng đúng không? Các bạn sẽ muốn bỏ theo
hàng. Còn mình mình đang muốn bỏ theo
cột thì mình phải để là số 1 này. Thì
các bạn nhìn thử nhá. Ví dụ này mình
dùng drop nhá. Drope này
đây. Drope đây đúng không? Giả sử đi
mình quên cái assist đi đúng không? Giả
sử bây giờ mình à ví dụ nhá mình drop
này đúng không? Mình drop mình bỏ mình
muốn bỏ cái cột này nhưng mà mình lại
quên mình không mình không chỉ ra cái
assist này mình để assist mặc định thì
nó sẽ dùng là nó là nó bỏ theo hàng. Bỏ
theo hàng thì kiểu gì nó cũng sai. Đây
các bạn nhìn chạy từ đây này. Bỏ theo
hàng thì kiểu gì cũng sai. Đây này.
Đấy sai chưa? Tại vì sao? Chả có cái
hàng nào tên là outcome cả. Được chưa?
Thì bây gi mình phải chỉ ra là tôi muốn
bỏ cột.
Các bạn có biết vì sao mà người ta lại
quy ước là axis bằng 0 là hàng, axis
bằng 1 là cột mà không phải ngược lại
không? Các bạn biết các bạn biết rằng
lại phải chỉ ra hàng chứ gì là cột? Vì
sao lại không là hàng, một là cột mà
không phải ngược lại?
Thì vì sao?
Không là bỏ theo hàng, một là bỏ theo
cột. Nhưng mà vì sao người ta lại quy
ước như thế?
Các bạn biết vì sao?
Vì sao nó dựa trên cái gì đây?
Nó dựa trên cái gì này? Vì sao người ta
lại quy ước là không là hàng, một là cột
mà không phải ngược lại?
Thì sao?
Có lý do gì không?
Tại vì
không không ừ thì đúng là record the
hàng thì đúng rồi nhưng mà nhưng mà sao
tại dùng không là hàng mà không phải
không là code sao không phải là 0 là 1
là row
vì sao tại vì là tại vì là một cái bảng
dữ liệu về mặt bản chất nó là một cái gì
một cái bảng. Một cái bảng như này. Một
cái bảng như này này. Một cái bảng như
này. Về mặt bản chất nó là một cái gì
các bạn?
Bảng bảng. Đúng rồi. Bảng nó là ma trận.
Chính xác. Bảng nó là mảng hai chiều. Ma
mảng hai chiều thì là ma trận. Đúng rồi.
Và khi nói về ma trận thì bao giờ ta
người ta nói kích thước của ma trận cũng
nói về số hàng trước đúng không? Ma trận
kích thước m nh n là m hàng n cột đúng
không? Bản thân chúng ta khi nói về ma
trận bao giờ chúng ta nói về số hàng
trước số cột sau đúng không? Thế nên là
khi người ta đánh chỉ số này người ta
đánh số hàng trước. Được chưa? Đấy đấy
là lý do vì sao mà không là nó đây không
chỉ áp dụng trong mỗi thư viện PAS này
đâu. Trong các cái thư viện khác trong
sau này bạn nào các bạn học cái khóa sau
khóa pay khóa de link for compation
chúng ta cũng y chang như vậy bao giờ
cũng ưu tiên hàng trước cột sau. Được
chưa? Đấy các bạn nhìn nhá. Bây giờ quay
ở đây được chưa?
Bây giờ axit bỏng 1 thì nó sẽ ok được
chưa? X đây đây chạy thì bình thường
chạy chạy ngon thôi chả vấn đề gì cả
được chưa? Y đây được chưa? XY đây chạy
chắc nó sẽ chả có vấn đề gì cả. Và bây
giờ ra xem trong mặt mũi như nào nhá.
Mình bô đây này. Được chưa? lại bổn cũ
xuất lại này. Xong ông lại click chuột
phải này được chưa? Chọn execute
selection in console nhá. Click vào đây
nhá. Được chưa? Chọn này x này. X này
đây. Thấy chưa? X này đúng không? Một
đấy đúng không? Mất đúng cái cột outcome
rồi. Đây là x đây là y. Đây là y được
chưa? Y của mỗi cái cột có mỗi cái cột
outcome thôi. Được chưa? Đấy các bạn
nhìn qua các bạn thấy kích kích thước
của nó đây không? Này là có 768 hàng tám
cột này. Còn này chỉ có 768 này thôi.
Tại vì là nó bị
nó chỉ một một cột thôi. Được chưa? Tách
xy. Rồi tách xy xong thì bây giờ chúng
ta mới tách tiếp là đây chúng ta đang bổ
theo chiều dọc. Chiều dọc t là gì? Tức
là xong bên y sang bên là bổ theo chiều
dọc đúng không? Một cái bộ rượu nó thẳng
như này các bạn bổ ra xong bên y sợ bên.
Tiếp theo bây giờ chúng ta sẽ bổ tiếp
theo chiều ngang. Chiều ngang là bộ tren
sang một bên bộ test sang một bên.
Lớp mình chắc chắn là có những bạn các
bạn đã từng dùng thư viện Sit learn rồi
đúng không? Nào các bạn nào các bạn chỉ
cho mình thư viện Sit learn là cái thư
viện quốc dân cho mạng chình đây này.
Nào trong sơn trong cái thư viện quốc
dân dành cho machine này có một cái hàm
người ta rất hay dùng để người ta phân
chia dữ liệu thành bộ chuên với bộ test.
Tên nó là cái gì các bạn nhỉ?
Ch split đúng rồi đúng không? Giả sử
nhá. Giả sử các bạn các bạn hỏi chat ch
chat chatvt ra ngay thôi nhưng mà giả
giả sử đi nếu mình không biết thì đúng
không? How to split ra
into train
and set đây sách lây đúng không đây
người ta cho các bạn kể cả không có chữ
k nhá kể không chữ sơn các bạn nhìn này
ra ngay kết quả đây này đây là hàm nội
dùng rất là nhiều trong sơn hàm này giúp
các bạn phân chia cái dượ của bạn thành
hai bộ đúng không hai bộ là bộ tren với
bộ test nhìn qua một tí nhá với những
bạn nào các bạn chúng ta chì trong lớp
sẽ có những bạn các bạn chưa dùng bao
giờ chúng ta sẽ nhìn qua một chút cái
tham số của nó thông thường các bạn nhá
những cái thư những cái thư viện những
cái framework như se này ấy người ta
viết những cái documentation nó rất là
chi tiết đấy các bạn từng hàm từng
phương thức từng class nó đều có những
cái entation nó rất là chi tiết
thế thì khi mà đọc này ấy nó sẽ có một
cái danh sách những cái tham số thông
thường những cái những cái tham số mà
quan trọng nhất ấy nó sẽ đẩy lên trên
thế nên này các bạn chỉ đọc một vài tham
số đầu tiên là đủ rồi đấy những cái
những cái tham số quan nhất là người ta
để hết lên trên ví dụ nhá cái array này.
Đây là nơi mà các bạn sẽ đưa vào x với
y. Đấy, đây này. Các bạn sẽ đưa vào x
với y. Các bạn có thể đưa xt. T. Các bạn
có đưa 4 năm mảng cũng được nhưng mà
thường ta chỉ đưa hai mảng thôi. Một
mảng là x và một mảng là y. Được chưa?
Đấy. Cái thứ nhất. Cái thứ hai nữa là
gì? Các bạn sẽ nhìn thấy chúng ta có sẽ
có hai cái tham số là test size với trên
size. Test size và trên size. Test size
là kích thức của bộ test và trên size là
kích thức của bộ trin. Các bạn nghe kỹ
nhá. nhá. Nghe kỹ này. Hai cái này ấy
các bạn chỉ điền một trong hai cái thôi.
Hoặc là điền test si hoặc là điền chên
si đừng bao giờ điền cả hai. Được chưa?
Khi mà các bạn điền các bạn chọn cái nào
cũng được.
Nếu các bạn chọn điền test sai hay chưa
sai ấy, các bạn sẽ có hai kiểu điền. Một
là các bạn điền số tự nhiên vào và hai
là các bạn điền số thực vào. Số thực
dương.
Nếu là số tự nhiên. Ví dụ cái test size
đi mình điền nó là 200. Test size bằng
200 có nghĩa là gì? Tức là cái bộ rượu
bạn các bạn sẽ dành ra 200 sle dành cho
bộ train và các bạn sẽ dành tất cả đống
còn lại dành cho bộ à xin lỗi test size
mà bằng 200 thì các bạn sẽ dành ra 200
sle cho bộ test và tất cả chỗ còn lạnh
dành bạn dành dành cho bộ trê được chưa?
Nếu các bạn điền bằng số số tự nhiên như
thế đúng không? In th số nguyên nhưng mà
đây các bạn chỉ điền số nguyên dương
thôi được chưa? Thế còn nếu không các
bạn điền tren size tr các bạn điền các
bạn điền là 1000 đi thì nó sẽ dành đúng
1000 sle cho bộ trend và chỗ còn lại
dành cho bộ test được chưa đấy là một
kiểu điền. Hai là các bạn dùng số số
thực. Nếu số thực ấy các bạn phải điền
một cái số từ 0 đến 1. Được chưa? Ví dụ
số thực ở đây các bạn điền là 0,2 cho bộ
test. Test sai bằng 0,2 nghĩa là gì? Tức
là bộ test sẽ là 0,2 là bằng 20%. Tức là
bộ test nó sẽ là 20% và 80% lại cho bộ
tren mà ngược lại trên size bằng 0,7
chẳng hạn thì nó sẽ dùng 70% cho bộ trên
và 30% lại cho bộ test. Được chưa? Không
bao giờ điển cả hai cái. Tại vì sao? Nếu
các bạn điền cả hai cái, chẳng may các
bạn điền ví dụ là test size các bạn để
bằng 0,3 trên size bằng 0,8. 0,8 + 0,3
nó quá 1 rồi thì nó sẽ làm gì? Nó sẽ làm
một cái hiện tượng gì? Là bộ test và bộ
tren sẽ có những cái x4 bị trùng nhau.
Được chưa? Thế nên là không bao giờ điền
cả hai ông này. Một là điền test, hai là
đi đến trên.
Được chưa? Không điền hai cái. Nếu các
bạn không điền test và cũng chẳng điền
train thì nó sẽ dùng mặc định là gì? Là
bộ test là 1/4, bộ train là 3/4. Được
chưa? Nếu các bạn không điền cái gì vào
thì test sẽ là 1/4 và train là 1/4. Được
chưa? Đấy đấy là cách các bạn dùng cái
hàm này. Dùng rất là dễ thôi. Đây là
những cái tham số quan trọng quan trọng
nhất.
Thì bây giờ mình sẽ
mình sẽ dùng thử cho các bạn xem. Dùng
thử cho các bạn xem nhá. Bây giờ ờ đây
import ấy thì rất là đơn giản. Đây
import đây nhá
nhá.
Form này được chưa?
Form cit learn đây nó cho sẵn mình luôn
này đúng không? Mình vừa tắt AI xong bại
nó nó hiện ra nhỉ các bạn. Chờ tí
trong lúc dậy thì mình tắt còn trong lúc
làm việc thì mình sẽ bật. Nhưng mà hôm
nọ mình nhớ mình tắt rồi sao b lại còn
lại nhỉ? Các bạn chờ một tí nhá. Editor
này
đâu ấ nhỉ?
Trong lúc trong trong lúc chúng ta đang
học mình không a mình không muốn ai nó
hiện ra lắm. Thế bây giờ nó hiện ra rồi
thì thì chả còn gì để chúng ta làm cả
đâu nữa nhỉ?
Plugin gì phảy
không phải nây.
Disable
nhá. Trong trong trong trong lúc học thì
mình không không muốn tại vì nó mà ai nó
hỗ trợ hết thì chả còn cái gì để học
nữa.
Chờ một tí nhá. Chờ một tí nhá. Chờ mình
reset lại nhá.
Chờ một xíu.
Đây
được chưa? Hi vọng là giờ nó hết rồi.
Rồi hết rồi đấy. Hết rồi đấy. À như bình
thường là tắt bật ở ở đây cũng được này.
Đúng rồi. Đây nhá. Mình tắt bớt rồi cho
nó cho chúng ta học cho nó dễ nhá.
Ta nói đâu rồi nhở? À tch dữ liệu ở đây
đúng không? Trên tit này xong mình sẽ
đây. Và các bạn nhìn những cái document
những cái documentation này bao giờ ở
cuối nó có một cái ví dụ đây. Ví dụ đây
này. Đấy ví dụ đây này. Các bạn copy ví
dụ nó nhá.
Ví dụ đây chẳng hạn nhá. Cho vào đây
này. Mình sẽ đổi một tí tại vì mình
không thích kiểu viết in này. Viết
thường này. Xin này.
X test này. Được chưa? X đây nhá.
Các bạn nhìn này. Tạm thời nhá. Ví dụ
đây nhá. Bằng 0,2 được chưa? Bằng 0,2
tức là gì? Tức là bộ test là 20% và bộ
trin là
bộ trin là 80% đúng không? Thì bây giờ
mình chạy thử nhá các bạn. Chạy thử này.
Chạy thử này.
Mình chạy thử nhá.
Đây các bạn nhìn này. Chờ một tí nhá.
Góc góc dưới bên phải nó sẽ hiện ra này.
Lần đầu chạy nó sẽ hơi lâu. Chạy sẽ hơi
lâu một chút tại vì là mình vừa mới khởi
lộp lại cái môi trường.
Đây rồi các bạn nhìn nhá. Đây này nhá.
Các bạn nhìn này. Bộ trê các bạn nhìn
thấy không? Nó có 614 sample.
Bộ test là có 154 đúng không? Tức là một
ông là 80% ông này 20 này. Đấy đúng
không? Đây này. Một ông ông chuyên là 80
ông test là 20. Các bạn nhìn nhá. Cái x
ban đầu ấy. X ban đầu các bạn nhìn này.
Cái x ban đầu ấy các bạn nhìn cái chỉ số
nó không 1 2 3 4 từng hàng một nhá.
Không vẫn đều đúng không? Nhưng bây gi
các bạn nhìn bộ trên này. Bộ trên này
các bạn nhìn chưa? Số nó lộn tùng phèo
chưa? Tức là gì? Tức là khi mà người ta
chia này ấ là người ta sẽ suffer ta sẽ
cháo lên. Cháo lên giống kiểu các bạn
cháo bài ấy. Đánh bài cháo bài để cho
đổi thứ tự đi đây. Đúng không? Tức là nó
sẽ chỉ đảm bảo gì? là bộ trin là 80%, bộ
test là 20% thôi. Thế còn cái cụ thể thứ
tự nào thì nó lộn lộn xộn đúng không? Nó
lộn xộn như này. Nó lộ xộn để cho khách
quan đấy. Tránh cái kiểu là lấy đúng 80%
đầu trên bộ trên 20% cuối trong bộ test
thì nó sẽ không có phù hợp lắm đúng
không? Đây nó cháo hết lên cho nó lấy ra
đúng không? Miễn là gì? Tổng số đ sample
của bộ test là 20% bộ trên là 80% là ok
rồi. Được chưa? Đây cách để các bạn có
thể phân chia thành bộ trên với bộ test.
Được chưa?
Rồi các bạn đấy các bạn nhân cái này các
bạn có thể đưa nhiều hơn cũng được nhưng
mà thường ta chỉ đưa x với y thôi tại vì
x là đầu vào và y là đầu ra hai bộ là đủ
rồi. Được chưa? Đến đây coi có câu hỏi
gì không?
Đến đây coi có câu hỏi gì không?
Có ai có câu hỏi thì không?
Thì nếu các bạn không hỏi thì mình hỏi
nhá. Ừ. Thế mình hỏi đây đây câu hỏi đây
câu hỏi đây. Nếu mình muốn có validation
set mình làm thế nào? Nếu mình muốn có
validation set mình làm thế nào? Bây giờ
cái hàm này nó chỉ tách ra hai bộ thôi.
Tôi muốn có ba bộ thì tôi làm nào bây
giờ? Đây chính là câu hỏi đây. Muốn có
ba bộ thì làm thế nào bây giờ?
Muốn có ba bộ thì làm nào?
Ừ đúng rồi. Chính xác chính xác ừ chị từ
bội trên đúng rồi đúng rồi. Chị tự bộ
trên đúng không? Ví dụ như này cũng chả
cần phải cho xuống dòng nhỉ. Cho trên
dòng cũng được mà
nhá. Th bộ trên nhá. Đúng không? Tách từ
đây đúng không? Nếu mà chúng ta thực sự
chúng ta cần bộ va ấy như này nhá. Xên
này. X va đúng không? Y trên này. Ya.
Đúng không? Tách ra đúng không?
X train. Y train.
Nhưng mình hỏi các bạn nhá. Bây giờ mình
muốn tỉ lệ của ba bộ trin, bộ va, bộ
test là 60 20. Tức là bộ tren là 60% bộ
va là 20, bộ test là 20. Thì theo các
bạn đây mình phải điền số nào vào đây?
Số Vân điền số mấy vào đây các bạn?
Mình muốn tỉ lệ là 60 20 mình điền số
mấy vào đây?
Đúng rồi. 0,25. Đúng rồi. Tính nhanh
nha. Mấy lớp trước của mình phải một lúc
mới có các bạn tìm ra cơ. Đúng rồi. 0,25
đúng không? Đấy. Nếu mà muốn đây thử
nhá. Thử này mà đúng không nhá. T đúng
là 60 20 không nhá.
Đây này. Bộ trên là 460 nhá. Bộ vào t là
đều trong 54 này. Được chưa? Đẹp chưa?
Đấy. Thế nhưng mà
nhưng mà trong thực tế thì người ta ít
khi người ta chia tức không phải ít khi
mà nếu mà cái bộ lúc ban đầu ấy đã qua
người ta chia sẵn rồi thì người ta sẽ
chia này. Còn không ấy người ta mà chưa
chia sẵn ấ thường thông thường người ta
chỉ chia thành bộ trên bộ test thôi. Còn
bộ va thì trong khi mình dùng cái KF
cross version thì mình sẽ tạo ra nó sau
đúng không? Này cho chỉ chia chưa đến
test thôi đúng không? Tí Kf cross chúng
ta sẽ lòi ra bộ va sau. Được chưa?
Rồi các bạn nhìn này, ở đây mình đã chia
thành hai bộ đúng không? Mình chạy mình
chạy thử một vài lần các bạn nhìn nhá.
Chạy thử một vài lần nhá. Mình chạy lần
đầu này. Lần đầu này đúng không? Nó sẽ
luôn đảm bảo là gì? Là train là 80% và
test là 20%. Các bạn nhìn nhá. Này tr
này tr nhá. Đây này. Các bạn để ý các
bạn để ý cho mình này. Các bạn để ý này.
Cái chỉ số đầu tiên cái sle đầu tiên của
bộ trên là 133 nhá. Để ý nhá. Số đầu
tiên của bộ trên là 133. Được chưa?
Tắt đi, tắt đi này. Chạy lại này.
C đầu tiên của bộ trên bây giờ là 454.
Được chưa? Lần nữa này.
Sample đầu tiên của bộ trên bây giờ lại
là 383.
Có nghĩa là gì? Có nghĩa là cứ mỗi một
lần mình chạy cái đoạn script này thì nó
lại ra một bộ trin và một bộ test khác
nhau. Nó chỉ đảm bảo là kích thước bộ
trin là 80% tổng dữ liệu và bộ test là
20% tổng dữ liệu thôi chứ nó không cố
định hai cái bộ này. Tức là gì? Mỗn lần
chạy nó nó ra random khác nhau đúng. Nó
chỉ đảm bảo tổng số liệu thôi. Theo các
bạn cái việc mà mỗi lần chạy, mỗi lần
mỗi lần chúng ta phân chia, tức là tất
nhiên chúng ta phân chúng ta muốn là khi
phân chia thành bộ chuyên về bộ test là
phải hoàn toàn ngẫu nhiên rồi đúng
không? Chúng ta muốn là phân chia hoàn
toàn ngẫu nhiên không theo một cái cơ
cấu chuẩn bị trước gì cả đúng không? Thế
nó mới công bằng đúng không? Chia bài là
phải chia ngẫu nhiên đúng không? Cháo
lên chia ngẫu nhiên thì nó mới công bằng
đúng không? Thế thế nhưng hiện tại ấy
chúng ta đang bị một lần bị là gì? Mỗi
lần chạy lại skin này nó lại ra một bộ
trên và một bộ và một bộ test khác đúng
không?
Tất nhiên bộ trên bộ test cộng lại thì
bằng tổng số lượng dữ liệu rồi đúng
không? Thế bộ một bộ này khác thì tự
nhiên là bộ kia cũng khác theo đúng
không? Ví dụ đây mình đ tập trung vào bộ
test đi. Theo các bạn bây giờ nếu cứ mỗi
lần mình mình phân chia này nó lại ra
một bộ test khác nhau nhá. Bộ test khác
nhau thì tự động bộ trên cũng sẽ khác
nhau. Tại vì hai bộ này tổng lại thì
đóng tổng số dữ liệu đúng không? Thế các
bạn cho mình hỏi này, nếu mỗi lần chạy
thế này ấ lại ra một bộ test khác nhau
thì theo các bạn nó sẽ có cái vấn đề gì?
Mỗi lần chạy lại có một bộ test khác
nhau thì nó sẽ có cái vấn đề gì ở đây?
Mỗi lần chạy
ư? Nào, Mae là cái gì? Mae là cái gì các
bạn? Minan absolute er mean absolute er
là magic dành cho bài toán gì các bạn?
Min absur là dành cho bài toán hồi quy
đúng không? Đây là bài toán phân loại mà
lần học sau có thể dính dữ liệu test của
trước không đúng. Tại vì sao? Mỗi lần
các bạn chạy đoạn script này là các bạn
sẽ huấn luyện mô hình lại một lần mô
hình mới tinh nên sẽ không có chuyện là
lần sau nó bị dính dáng gì của lần
trước. Không có đúng không? Tí nữa mình
huấn luyện mỗi lần mình chạy, mỗi lần
mình huấn luyện là mình sẽ huấn luyện
lại lần từ từ đầu mà đúng không? Ông lần
sau có dây mơ dễ má gì vâng lần lần
trước đâu. Không phải đấy không phải vấn
đề
t huấn luyện thì
không hẳn tại vì là chúng ta huấn luyện
đâu có gì đảm bảo là các bạn chạy một
phát là được mô hình tốt luôn đâu. Chạy
mô hình các bạn huấn luyện các bạn chạy
nhiều lần là chuyện bình thường đúng
không? Chứ giống như kiểu mình đi học
ngày xưa cũng thế thôi. Làm gì cái
chuyện là vừa vào học phát đã làm được
bài ngay đâu. Kiểu gì chả phải làm sai
một vài lần thì mới làm đúng chứ. Đúng
không?
Nào nó sẽ vấn đề gì? Nếu cứ mỗi lần chạy
biết là nó phân trên ngẫu nhiên rồi
nhưng mà cứ mỗi lần chạy nó lại ra một
cái bộ test khác nhau thì nó sẽ có cái
vấn đề gì?
Nó khó đánh giá. Khó đánh giá là khó
đánh giá như thế nào? Đội chính xác khác
nhau. Ừ. Đội sác một lần khác nhau nó sẽ
uống lên. Ừ. N độ chính xác khác nhau
thì làm sao?
Check lot cho dễ. Check l cho dễ á. Not
really.
Bộ test phải cố định.
Ừ thì nhưng mà đây mỗi lần mình chạy ra
một bộ test khác nhau thì làm sao? Ừ như
này là bộ test nó không cố định rồi. Thế
nhưng mà bộ test không cố định thì bị
làm sao? Mỗi lần chạy ra kết quả khác
nhau. Ừ thì đúng. Mỗi lần chạy ra kết
quả khác nhau. Đúng thì như mỗi chạy ra
kết quả khác nhau thì làm sao? Tại vì
mình chạy, mình muốn cải thiện mô hình
thì lần sau nó phải tốt hơn lần trước
thì chạy kết quả khác nhau chuyện bình
thường đúng không?
Hiện tại ấ nếu mà chạy cái này cứ mỗi
lần nó lại đẻ ra một bộ test khác nhau.
Bộ test luôn chỉ có 154 phần tử nhưng mà
mỗi lần bộ test khác nhau.
Đánh ra sai không? Đánh ra sai độ chính
xác đâu. Đánh ra tốt đấy chứ. Đánh ra
tốt không phải đánh ra tốt đánh đánh giá
đúng ấy chứ. Có sai gì đâu.
Nếu kết quả tốt thì không biết mô hình
tốt hay
Nếu kết quả tốt không biết mô hình tốt
hay chư ta hen. Ư
mình chạy xong gửi mô hình cho người
khác chạy thì kết quả nó không giống
nhau thô đây. Không nhất cũng không hẳn
nha. Tại vì như thế này. Ví dụ các bạn
bây giờ các bạn chạy mô hình các bạn
được độ chính xác là 80% ông kia chạy ví
dụ 80,5 lệch một tí. Ừ. Nhưng mà nó cũng
tức là đúng là nó không đúng nó không
đồng nhất nhưng mà nó cũng không nó cũng
không đến mức là biến ra từ mô hình tốt
hẳn đến mô hình sai hẳn nhưng mà nó có
một cái vấn đề nó có vấn đề then chốt ở
cái việc là nếu mà mỗi lần chúng ta chạy
này nó ra ra một bộ test khác nhau nó sẽ
như thế nào không nó không bị trộn nó
không hề bị trộn nó không hề bị trộn mỗi
lần lần trước và lần sau nó không dây mơ
dễ má gì cả lần nào nó cũng đảm bảo là
gì là bộ chuyên là 80% bộ test là 20%
lần nào nó cũng đảm bảo
>> [khịt mũi]
>> sẽ một cái vấn đề như này đúng không?
Vừa nãy bạn à
mỗi mô hình ra một thôi các bạn nó nói
nó như thế này các bạn nhá.
Đúng là lúc đầu chúng ta dùng cái hàm
chúng ta dùng cái hàm trên test split
này để làm gì? Để chúng ta có thể tách
ra bộ tren và bộ test một cách ngẫu
nhiên. Đúng không? Chúng ta muốn tách bộ
tren và bộ test một cách ngẫu nhiên.
Thế nhưng cái chúng ta cần là gì? Chúng
ta cần cái sự ngẫu nhiên này nó phải cố
định. Tức là lần nào nó cũng ngẫu nhiên
giống y chang như thế. Tại vì sao? Tại
vì nếu nó ngẫu nhiên một cách không có
định ấ mỗi lần ra một cái bộ test khác
nhau nó sẽ có vấn đề này là các bạn sẽ
không so sánh được giữa các cái lần huấn
luyện với nhau. Các bạn tưởng tượng này
hôm qua các bạn huấn luyện mô hình xong
rồi các bạn được một cái mô hình có cái
accuracy là 80% chứ gì đúng không? Hôm
nay các bạn thử cải thiện một là các bạn
cải thiện là các bạn tiền xử lý rượu
theo kiểu khác. Các bạn tiền xử lý một
kiểu cao cấp hơn hoặc các bạn thay một
cái mô hình mới hoặc các bạn làm cái lọ
cái chai gì đấy đúng không? Các bạn cải
thiện cái gì đấy ở cái squit của bạn?
Một là ở mô hình, hai là ở rượu, ba là ở
cái gì đấy đúng không? Và bây giờ các
bạn huấn luyện mô hình xong các bạn thấy
là hôm nay được 81%.
Hôm qua được 80, hôm nay hôm nay được
81. Thế nhưng nếu các bạn không cố định
được cái bộ test ấy thì các bạn sẽ không
chứng minh được là cái kết quả tốt hơn
của hôm nay so với hôm qua là đến từ cái
kỹ thuật mới của bạn hoặc đến từ cái mô
hình mới của bạn. Tại vì sao? Tại vì có
thể hoàn toàn là hôm qua trong cái bộ
test thì có nhiều cái sle nó khó. Hôm
nay trong bộ test thì lại nhiều sle nó
dễ đúng không? Thế nên nếu nó giống như
kiểu bạn nào các bạn đã từng làm trong
doanh nghiệp các bạn các bạn làm làm làm
về thống kê các bạn biết có một cái
người ta gọi là AB testing đấy. AB
testing có nghĩa là gì? Có nghĩa là bây
giờ ví dụ các bạn AB testing có nghĩa là
AB là AB đấy. AB testing có nghĩa là gì?
Tức là bây giờ giả sử các bạn thiết kế
các bạn thiết kế trang web nhá. Đúng
không? Trang web bây giờ các bạn đang
phân vân xem là cái trang web này tôi
nên nên làm cái cái cái màu chủ đề là
màu tối hay là màu sáng đúng không? Thì
bây giờ các bạn muốn biết cái màu nào
tốt hơn thì các bạn sẽ làm thế nào nhỉ?
Các bạn sẽ làm hai cái thiết kế đúng
không? Hai cái trang web giống yên nhau.
Nó chỉ khác nhau mỗi một gì? Là một ông
là cái cái tông màu sáng, một ông là
tông màu tối đúng không? Sau các bạn sẽ
deploy hai cái trang web này lên hai
nhóm đối tượng khách hàng. Hai nhóm này
sẽ tương đồng nhau về mặt là tỉ lệ nam
nữ, tỉ lệ già trẻ, tỉ lệ các cái thứ y
hệt nhau. Tôi sẽ chỉ thay đổi khác mỗi
một là cái là cái tông màu của cái trang
web thôi. Thì bây giờ nếu các bạn thấy
là cái cái cái nhóm nào người ta truy
cập trong web nhiều hơn, các bạn sẽ biết
là à cái tông m này nó tốt hơn đúng
không? Thìở đây nó cũng y chang như vậy.
Bây giờ ấy nếu các bạn các bạn cố hai
cái lần training ấy các bạn cố định mọi
thứ. Các bạn chỉ có khác mỗi là gì? là
tôi một là tôi đổi cái mô hình khác, hai
là tôi đổi cách tiền x tiền dữ dệu khác.
Thì nếu bây giờ cái mô hình của lần A
tốt kiểu của của lần X lớn hơn tốt hơn
lần Y ấy thì các bạn sẽ biết ngay là tốt
hơn là do cái việc là các bạn tiền xí
hoặc là do các bạn đổi mô hình đúng
không? Chứ còn nếu bây giờ các bạn vừa
đổi mô hình các bạn vừa đổi bộ test thì
lúc này khi mà mô hình nó tốt hơn các
bạn sẽ không biết là tốt hơn là do cái
gì đúng không? Tại vì trong quá trình
chúng ta huấn luyện mô hình đúng rồi tức
là gì? Nếu có một cái gì khác biệt giữa
hai cái thí nghiệm này thì cái sự khác
biệt đấy hoặc là nó chỉ đến từ mô hình
hoặc là nó chỉ đến từ dữ liệu thế thôi.
Thẳc đến mô hình hoặc hay là đến từ cách
tiền xí rượu thôi chứ không thể nào vừa
mô hình vừa là bộ test hoặc là vừa tiền
sĩ rượu vừa bộ test được đúng không? Cả
mô hình cũng thế. Không thể nào các bạn
vừa thay đổi cách xử lý mô hình à vừa
thay đổi cách tiền xử lý dữ liệu, vừa
thay đổi mô hình. Tại vì các bạn làm cả
hai cái đồ thời các bạn sẽ không biết là
tốt hơn là do cái nào đúng không? Thì
cái rượu vậy cũng thế. Chúng ta muốn là
gì? Chúng ta muốn là cái bộ test ấy lúc
nào nó cũng phải cố định. Thì khi bộ
test cố định rồi tôi sẽ biết là các cái
lần tôi huấn luyện lần nào là lần tốt
nhất đúng không? Tức là gì? Tôi phân
chia dữ liệu một cách ngẫu nhiên nhưng
ngẫu nhiên phải cố định. Ngẫu nhiên cố
định có nghĩa là gì? Nghĩa là lần nào nó
cũng phải ngẫu nhiên giống y trang như
thế đúng không? Để tôi có thể tôi so
sánh giữa cái lần tôi huấn luyện với
nhau. Tôi biết là à lần này huấn luyện
tốt, lần kia huấn luyện tồi đúng không?
Lần này tốt hơn lần kia, lần này tối hơn
lần kia. Kiểu như vậy được chưa?
Rồi được chưa? Thế bây giờ ấy để cố định
được cái như vậy ấ thì tôi sẽ cần thêm
một cái tham số nữa. Cái tham số mà giúp
để cố định cái sự ngẫu nhiên ấy người ta
gọi là random state. Rom state.
Được chưa? SS này các bạn cho nó một con
số bao nhiêu cũng được. Ví dụ mình cho
ngày sinh của mình 109 vào. Cho số mấy
vào cũng được, miễn là số dương nhá. Số
dương các bạn cho số mấy cũng được.
Nhưng một khi các bạn đã cho số nào rồi
thì muôn đời các bạn phải để đúng cái số
đây. Được chưa? Nếu ở đây mình cho xuống
dòng nhìn dễ nhá. Nếu ở đây mình đã để
cái số là 1009 rồi thì muôn đời mình
phải để số này. Mình không được đổi số
khác. Thì khi bạn nhìn nhá cái đ khi
mình để cố định này mình sẽ chạy này
chạy thử này chạy thử nhá
đây
nhìn nhá bộ tren này bộ tren này bộ tren
đây nhá các bạn nhìn không cái ông đầu
tiên là 498 này 498 705 nhá được chưa
498 là cái hàng đầu tiên là chỉ số hàng
đầu tiên 705 này 498 705 này chạy lại
này
chạy lại nhá chạy lại
Đây nhá. Các bạn thấy không? Vẫn 498705.
Được chưa? Lần nữa này. Lần nữa này.
Lần nữa này.
Vẫn 498705. Được chưa? Tức là gì? Tôi
phân chia dữ liệu ngẫu nhiên nhưng ngẫu
nhiên một cách cố định đúng không? Bộ
trên không đổi thì tức là bộ test cũng
không đổi. Bộ test không đổi các bạn sẽ
xoánh được giữa 10 lần các bạn huấn
luyện xem lần nào là lần tốt nhất đúng
không? Đấy là cái điểm các bạn phải chú
ý về phân chia dữ liệu đúng không? Phân
chia dữ liệu ngẫu nhiên nhưng phải ngẫu
nhiên một cách cố định để đảm bảo là lần
nào nó cũng ra đúng cái bộ test đấy đúng
không? Bộ chuyên thay đổi thì cũng được
nhưng mà vì cái bộ test chúng ta cần cố
định mà bộ test với bộ trên lại là phần
bù của nhau cộng lại thì đấy đúng tổng
dữ liệu đúng không? Nên là nên là có
nghĩa là gì? Có nghĩa là lần nào cũng
đúng cái bộ trên đấy được chưa? Công
bảng đúng không? 10 lần tôi huấn luyện
dùng đúng một cái bộ để trên và dùng
đúng một cái bộ để test. Được chưa?
Đấy. Thế là chúng ta đã chúng ta đã bổ
rượu theo chiều dọc rồi. Chúng ta bổ
rượu theo chiều ngang rồi đúng không?
Theo các bạn bước tiếp theo chúng ta làm
cái gì tiếp?
Bộ vai thì tí nước. Bộ va thì tí nữa nói
rồi. Bộ va thì thông thường như mình nói
tức là người ta sẽ không chia kiểu chia
thành ba bộ đầu mà người ta sẽ dùng cái
KF cross version trong buổi chúng ta học
lý thuyết đúng không? KF Cross Fion thì
nó sẽ dùng như vậy thì nó sẽ giúp chúng
ta có thể tối ưu số lượng sample dành
cho bộ train đúng không? Thế nên ở đây
mình mới chỉ chia làm hai bộ thôi. Mình
không chia làm bộ va. Tí nữa mình dùng
KF cross version các bạn sẽ biết là bộ
va nằm ở đâu nhá.
Nào đến đây chúng ta làm gì tiếp bây
giờ?
Đến đây làm gì? Tiếp các bạn nhỉ?
À đúng rồi, phải tiền xử lý dữ liệu.
Phải tiền xử lý dữ liệu đúng không? Phải
tiền xử lý đã đúng không? Tiền xử lý.
Fit ở trên chưa? Tại vì là mình chưa fit
vào trên được ngay đâu. Tại vì là đã có
mô hình đâu đúng không? Mô hình thì chưa
có, dữ liệu thì cũng chưa tiền xử lý
đúng không? Chưa cho vào ngay được đâu
nhá.
Ok. Nghỉ giá 5 phút nhá. Nghỉ giờ 5 phút
thì chúng ta học tiếp nhá. Nào
mà các bạn muốn hỏi thì các bạn cứ hỏi
nhá. Mình vẫn ngồi trước máy thôi nhá.
Đọc pháo một tí bị hay không?
Vậ anh ơi em hỏi anh một câu được không
anh? Ừ ừ em hỏi đi em hỏi đi hỏi thoải
mái
>> à dạ dạ hiện tại em đang làm về cái ờ
cái project nó sẽ liên quan kiểu xây
dựng mô hình về data mặt theo theo thời
gian của anh thì không biết khóa này của
mình thì anh có hướng dẫn về
ờ là data theo thời gian không anh ha?
>> Ờ em em nói lại tí không anh chưa nghe
rõ data data gì em nhỉ?
Dạ. Data time series à time save for
casting. Có có có mình có time save for
casting.
Vâng được ạ. Được ạ. Được ạ. Được ạ. Học
xong em ạ. Ngon time save for casting
đúng không? Có có này
xong xong xong bài xong bài bài này cái
project thứ thứ tư chúng ta đây là đây
là pro thứ nhất đúng không? Số X thứ tư
ta sẽ về time C for casting như này này.
Đây kiểu như bộ CO2 này. Cái bộ mình app
cho các bạn trên Google Drive này. Time
C for casting này. Được chưa?
>> Ừ.
Hiện tại không phải là mình huấn luyện
với phần lớn của bộ trên đâu mà mình
đang huấn luyện với toàn bộ của bộ tren
đấy. Đúng không? Hiện tại bộ va chưa
xuất hiện thì mình đang huấn luyện với
toàn bộ bộ tren
được chưa mọi người? Mọi người có nhớ
cái K focus variation lần trước mình dạy
không các bạn nhỉ? Mở lại nhá.
Không biết qua kênh nghỉ mọi người còn
nhớ không? Mình dạy rồi đúng không? K
cross variation đâu nhỉ?
Đây rồi.
Lớp mình là lớp đầu tiên mình mình dạy
theo cái slide này.
Đây cho nhanh này. Lâu quá.
đâu ấy nhỉ?
A chưa
sao mình chưa dạy à?
Lớp mình m mình đã nói về cái K4 cross
variation bao giờ chưa các bạn nhỉ? Sao
mình cứ đinh đinh là mình nói rồi nhỉ? H
là chưa à?
À chưa có thật
rồi sao tí dừng nghỉ 5 phút mình nói
mình cứ đinh đình này mình cho rồi ơ đây
không được không thấy có đấy nhở
ờ chưa thấy có thật nhá tí tí tí m các
bạn đây là cách chia truyền thống nên có
một cách chia khác người ta sẽ trong
thực tế người ta sẽ hay dùng hơn cách
thay vì người ta chia cố định này người
ta sẽ sao mình cứ nhớ là mình nói rồi
nhỉ
đây À
balance.
Ừ chưa nói rồi. Chưa nói rồi. Rồi không
sao. Tí nghỉ 5 phút xong mình sẽ nói
nhá.
Cái gì đây nhỉ?
>> [khịt mũi]
>> Đây là intern từ
tuyển intern này các bạn. Có bạn nào ở
trong Hồ Chí Minh với Đà Nẵng không này
chả biết công ty nào đây.
Có bạn nào có nhu cầu không thì mình
forw
intern 3 tháng này.
Python này, giải tích này
tạo sinh này làation này là
communication
không có job description nhỉ.
Không đây. Tí tí nữa tí nữa nhá. Tí nữa.
Wait a second nhá.
Cứ đinh đinh là nói rồi. [hắng giọng]
>> Thầy em hỏi một chút được không ạ?
>> Ừ ừ
>> thầy em hơi bị rối rối chỗ vừa nãy thầy
mô tả là bộ trên bộ test ấy ạ. Thì hiện
tại là em hiểu là mình đang
>> chưa nói gì bộ va cả. Ừ
>> thì nếu mà bộ test mà cố định rồi ấy thì
hiện tại là mình dùng toàn bộ số liệu
của bộ trên đúng không thầy?
>> Đúng rồi.
>> Thế thì tầm sao? Em tưởng thì nó sẽ fix
luôn cả bộ trên chú ạ.
>> Từ fix đây từ tiếng Việt mình có nghĩa
là gì nhỉ?
>> Ý ý ý em hiểu nhá. Ví dụ như là mình có
bộ bài là ví dụ bộ bài của mình có 52
quân đi.
>> Ừ
>> mình chia quân từ số 40 đến 52 là bộ
test. Ví dụ thế nhá. À
>> tức là bộ trên của mình đang có quân từ
quân số 1 đến quân quân số 39 đúng không
ạ?
>> Đúng rồi.
>> Thì bây giờ như em hiểu nhá là bộ bộ
test là mình đang đang cố định rồi. Tức
là quân 40 đến quân 52 là cố định là
>> à fix ý và fix đây là cố định đúng
không?
>> Vâng.
>> Ừ fix fix cố định là fix ID nữa. Còn ừ
ok mình tưởng mấy các bạn vào đảo sửa
cái gì. Ừ ok. Vậy thì em thắc mắc là nếu
như mà bộ bộ
test đã cố định rồi á thì thầy bảo là
dùng toàn bộ bộ trên để mình huấn luyện
thì bộ trên cái số sample của nó cũng là
sẽ là tất cả là 39 quân chư ạ.
>> Ừ.
Ừ. Nếu nếu nếu mình dùng toàn toàn bộ bộ
chuyên thì đúng là 39 vân. Đúng rồi.
>> Nhưng mà như thế thì lần nào mình huấn
luyện cũng là đúng cái bộ đó chứ thầy.
>> Đúng rồi. Chính xác. Chính xác. Hoàn
toàn chính xác. Exactly.
>> Exactly. Nếu vậy thì sự khác biệt nếu mà
kết quả nó khác nhau thì chỉ nó khác
nhau ở cái phần là mình mình
tiền xử lý dữ liệu đúng không thầy? Còn
lại số liệu nó vẫn thế thôi.
>> Chính xác hoặc là tiền xử lý hoặc là
mình thay đổi mô hình hoặc là một cái lọ
cái chai. Thế đ chính xác là như thế.
Chính xác là như thế
đúng rồi. Thế nên mình phải cố định đấy.
Tại vì gì? Giống kiểu AB testing ấy. Tức
là gì? Tôi thay đổi, tôi chỉ thay đổi
một cái thôi. Thì nếu có cái sự khác
biệt là từ cái sự khác từ từ cái khác
biệt đấy. Đúng không? Cho nên nếu có hai
thứ khác biệt nhau vừa mô hình khác nhau
lại vừa bộ test khác nhau thì lúc này
tôi sẽ không biết là cái sự tốt hơn nó
nó đến từ đâu đúng không? Đấy là cái bản
chất của AB testing là gì? Varient là
chỉ variant ở một thứ thôi. Hai trang
web khác nhau hoặc là chỉ khác nhau ở
cái tông màu thôi hoặc là khác nhau ở
cái giao diện thôi hoặc là khu khác nhau
ở chức năng thôi chứ khác nhau đồng thời
cùng nhiều thứ thì tôi sẽ không biết là
khách hàng họ dùng cái trang web này
nhiều hơn phiên bản nhiều hơn là do cái
gì do họ thích cái tông màu hơn hay
thích giao diện hơn hay họ thích cái
chức năng hơn đúng không?
>> Vâng.
>> Ừ.
>> Thế thì vậy là hiện tại là mình chỉ đánh
giá là hiệu quả của tiền xử lý dữ liệu
lên kết quả đúng không thầy? Không, mình
cũng chưa tiền xử lý luôn. Mình cũng
chưa tiền xử lý gì cả. Mình mới mình mới
chia dữ liệu thôi. Mình mình chưa tiền
cái gì cả. Chưa tiền n gì ở đây cả. Mình
đã làm cái gì đâu. Mình mới chỉ tách dữ
liệu thôi mà.
>> À không em em em thắc mắc là nếu như mà
mình đã cố định cả hai bộ rồi ấ thì hiệu
quả chỉ đến là từ việc tiền xử lý thôi
nhỉ?
>> Chưa chắc. Có thể là họ chỉ thay đổi mô
hình thôi. Họ không khác thay đổi các
tiền xử lý. Họ chỉ thay đổi mô hình
thôi. Nó còn nhiều thứ lắm. Ừ
>> nhá. Ok. Rồi các bạn tiếp này. Hôm chúng
ta học ấy mình cứ đinh đinh là nói rồi.
Các bạn nhìn này. Đây là cách phân chia
truyền thống đúng không? Đây là cách
phân chia rượu truyền thống để có thể
phân cái bộ rượu chúng ta ra làm ba bộ
con là bộ trin, bộ va và bộ test. Được
chưa? Ba bộ này yêu cầu là gì? Là không
được overlap với nhau. Không overlap gì.
một sample chỉ có thể hoặc là rơi vào bộ
trin hoặc là rơi vào bộ va hoặc là rơi
vào bộ tép mà thôi. Thế thế nếu mà các
bạn gặp những cái bộ dữ liệu mà ngay từ
đầu người ta đã chia sẵn cho các bạn
thành ba bộ ấy thì các bạn dùng thì ok
không vấn đề. Thế nhưng nếu mà lúc đầu
người ta cho các bạn rượu là một cục và
trong hầu hết các tình huống thường là
một cục mà các bạn buổ về các bạn tự
chia ấy thì thông thường các cái data
scientist và maching engineer ấy họ sẽ
rất là ít khi mà họ phân chia làm ba bộ
như này. Họ sẽ rất là ít khi chia làm ba
bộ này và họ sẽ chỉ làm chia làm hai bộ
thôi. Các bạn nhìn nhá mình hãy chỉ cho
các bạn cái vấn đề khi chúng ta sẽ gặp
phải khi chúng ta chia làm ba bộ thế
này. Được chưa? Trong ba cái bộ này, bộ
test là cái bộ mà luôn luôn là phải có
riêng một khúc rồi. Bộ test thì không
nói làm gì, bộ test kiểu gì cũng phải
có. Tại vì nó là giống cái bài thiếp
chuông phổ thông ấy. Muốn học ở đâu thì
học kiểu gì cũng phải có cái bài thi tốt
nghiệp trung phổ thông. Nên là bộ test
là không tiết kiệm được. Được chưa? Thế
bây các bạn nhìn này nhá. Bộ test thì
không tiết kiệm được. Các bạn nhìn đây.
Thế bây giờ mình sẽ vẽ này nhá. Bộ test
bình thường đây. Bên trên là ba bộ nhá.
Nhìn này.
Đây nhá. Bộ trên đây nhá.
Đúng không? Bình thường bộ tren này được
chưa? Bộ trê là một cục to nhá. Bộ va là
một cục nữa và bộ test là một cục nữa.
Bộ test là một cục nữa. Được chưa? Bao
giờ bộ trên thì cũng là bộ to nhất đúng
không? Bộ tr này
bộ validation đấy. Và bộ test đúng
không? Trong ba cái bộ này ấy, hãy tạm
thời bỏ qua bộ test đi. Bộ test là kiểu
gì cũng phải có rồi. Kiểu gì là cũng
phải tách phần dệu cho bộ test thôi. Bộ
test thì không tiết kiệm được. Nhưng mà
hãy nói về bộ chuyên và và bộ và bộ va.
Các bạn nhìn nhá. Bộ chên bộ va này
trong ba bộ của chúng ta ấy, trong ba
cái bộ này ấ trong ba cái bộ này trên va
với test ấy thì thật ra cái bộ duy nhất
mà nó thực sự nó trực tiếp nó ảnh hưởng
nó tác động đến nó giúp cho mô hình tốt
hơn nó thực sự nó là cái đứa nó chìa tay
ra nó chạm tay vào nó đóng góp nó giúp
cho mình tốt hơn là bộ trê bộ chuyên là
cái mô hình nó giúp cho mình tốt hơn còn
thật ra bộ va và bộ test nó không giúp
cho mô hình tốt
Ngày xưa các bạn đi học ấy, các bạn đi
học lớp phổ thông ấy, lớp các bạn học
học lớp 12 đi các bạn học toán hàng
ngày. Cái thứ mà giúp cho các bạn tốt
hơn là những bài học hàng ngày của cô.
Hàng ngày các bạn học đạo hàm, tích
phân, khảo sát hàm số, giải tích các thứ
đúng không? Hàng ngày cái bài học hàng
ngày ấy là cái thứ giúp cho bạn học tốt
hơn. Bài thi học kỳ nó không giúp cho
bạn học tốt hơn. Bài thi học kỳ nó không
giúp cho các bạn trở thành một phiên bản
tốt hơn của bạn. Bài thi tốt nghiệp chu
phổ thông càng không giúp cho các bạn
tốt hơn đúng không các bạn? Công nhận
không? Bài thi cuối kỳ và bài thiêu chu
phổ thông. Các bạn làm xong hai cái bài
thi đấy, các bạn không giỏi hơn một chút
nào đúng không? Bài thi cuối kỳ và bài
thi tốt nghiệp ch phổ thông. Hai bài đấy
các bạn làm xong các bạn không tốt lên
một tí ti nào. Hai báy ra đời nó chỉ
nhằm mỗi một cái nhiệm vụ là gì các bạn
nhỉ? Bài thi học kỳ với bài thi chu phổ
thông ra đời nó để nó đểm làm cái gì?
Làm cái gì?
Chấm điểm. Đúng rồi. Xem các bạn học đến
đâu đúng không? Hai nó không giúp bạn
tốt hơn. Bộ test thì như mình nói, bộ
test là bắt buộc phải có rồi, không có
tiết kiệm được đúng không? Nhưng hãy nói
về bộ va đi. Bộ va về một về mặt bản
chất nó không giúp cho các bạn học giỏi
hơn.
Thế thì khi mà tôi phân chia bộ trơ này
một cục, bộ va này một cục, bộ tch thành
một cục ấy thì với cái bộ vai này rõ
ràng là chúng ta đang
tốn một cái lượng dữ liệu nhất định để
làm một cái việc mà nó không thực sự nó
giúp cho mình tốt hơn đúng không? Bộ vai
nó chỉ nó đánh giá trong quá trình huấn
luyện thôi đúng không? Ngày xưa các bạn
thi học kỳ là để chỉ để cô biết là à các
bạn đang học đúng hướng hay không thôi
chứ còn bộ van nó chả giúp gì cho các
bạn giỏi hơn cả. Làm xong bài kiếm làm
xong cái bài bài kiểm tra cuối kỳ không
ai giỏi hơn cả đúng không? Không ai giỏi
hơn nhờ làm bài thi cuối kỳ cả. Được
chưa? Thế thì bây giờ chúng ta nghĩ ra
một cái trích là gì? Bộ test như mình
nói rồi bắt buộc phải tốn không nói gì.
Nhưng về bộ trên và bộ va bây giờ thay
vì thay vì người ta phân cứng thành bộ
chuyên một cục bộ va cục như vậy thì lúc
nào các bạn cũng sẽ bị một lãng phí cái
chỗ này đúng không? Thì bây giờ ta sẽ
làm như này. Người ta sẽ không phân chia
như vậy nữa.
Người ta sẽ làm như này. Bây giờ người
ta sẽ
bộ test thì ở ngoài không nói nhá. Chỉ
nói bộ chơ bộ va. Thì bây giờ như này,
thay vì tôi phân chia cứng bộ chên bộ
van như vậy thì bây giờ tôi sẽ làm thế
này. Tôi sẽ đầu tiên tôi sẽ cần phải có
xếp một cái số k. Số k là số tự nhiên số
một số tự nhiên. Ví dụ k = 4 đi. K = 4
đi. Ví dụ k = 4 nhá. K = 4. Thì bây giờ
k = 4 ấy, tôi sẽ chia cái đống rượu của
tôi sau khi tôi đã có bộ test riêng ra
rồi đúng không? Thì cái chỗ còn lại đây
vẫn chia làm bốn phần đúng không? Bốn
phần. Và tôi cũng sẽ lập lại đúng bốn
lần.
Đấy.
Được chưa?
K bằng bao nhiêu thì các bạn sẽ chia bộ
rượu thành thành từng đấy phần bằng nhau
về mặt số lượng và các bạn sẽ đ lại đúng
bốn lần như vậy. Được chưa? Thế bây giờ
giả sử các bạn đang muốn huấn luyện cái
mô hình, ví dụ các bạn đang muốn huấn
luyện mô hình random for chẳng hạn đúng
không? Các bạn có một cái mô hình random
fres thì bây gi các bạn sẽ làm cái việc
này là bây giờ các bạn sẽ huấn luyện cái
mô hình random fred này bốn lần song
song nhá. Được chưa? Bốn lần song song
tức là gì? Song song và độc lập không
lần nào liên quan đến lần nào. Đây mô
hình các bạn đây. Mô hình model machine
đây đúng không? Các bạn huấn luyện nó
bốn lần hoàn toàn song song độc lập với
nhau. Cái lần đầu tiên các bạn sẽ lấy
cái khúc cuối là bộ va. Lần này bộ va,
bộ va và bộ va. Tức là gì? Mỗi lần này
mỗi lần sẽ có một cái bộ va khác nhau.
Và những cái chỗ còn lại sẽ là một bộ
chuê. Được chưa? Lần đầu các bạn huấn
luyện xong các bạn được cái các bạn có
thể được cái loss. Loss là bao nhiêu
đấy? Loss là L1. Cái thứ hai loss là L2.
Loss là L3. Lost là L4. Ví dụ như vậy
đúng không? Sau các bạn tính cái lot
hoặc là các bạn tính er gì đấy đúng
không? Hoặc là các bạn tính acua muốn
tính cái gì thì tính đúng không? Tính
trung bình cộng trung bình chia trung
bình ra đúng không? Chia chia chia chia
trung bình đi. E của L này đúng không?
Tính trung bình ra. Được chưa? Thế thì
cái giá cái giá trị trung bình này ấy
chính là cái điểm mà chúng ta đang chấm
cho cái mô hình của tôi đúng không? Bình
thường là tôi phải có một cái bộ va
riêng. Đây thì tôi sẽ không phải có một
bộ va riêng nó sẽ linh động đúng không?
Mỗi một mô hình nó sẽ có một cái bộ va
riêng. Được chưa? Tôi vẫn đảm bảo là gì?
là cái mô hình này bốn lần huấn luyện
tôi là mỗi một lần là bộ chuyên bộ vai
nó không overlap với nhau. Được chưa?
Thế sau khi mà tôi đã huấn luyện xong
như này rồi ấy, tôi biết là cái mùi của
tôi nó có cái điểm như nào rồi. Tại vì
tôi dựa vào đây này. Tôi dựa vào
cho tôi.
Sau khi mà tôi đã sau khi mà tôi đã dựa
vào đâu rồi?
Sau khi mà tôi đã dựa cái điểm này rồi
thì tôi sẽ huấn luyện mô hình một lần
cuối. Lần cuối cùng này, lần cuối cùng
này tôi sẽ huấn luyện cái vẫn cái mô
hình random forest này vẫn huấn luyện từ
đầu nhưng lần cuối này tôi sẽ huấn luyện
cái mô hình này với toàn bộ dữ liệu. Có
bao nhiêu thầy huấn luyện hết. Tất nhiên
là bộ test ra ngoài không nói rồi đúng
không? Tôi sẽ huấn luyện với toàn bộ
rượu. Tôi sẽ không phân thành bộ chuyên
bộ va nữa. Tôi sẽ huấn luyện với toàn bộ
rượu này. Được chưa? Thì tôi vẫn đảm bảo
gì? Tôi vẫn có một cái cơ chế để tôi
đánh giá cái khả năng của mình của tôi
mà tôi lại vừa tối đa hóa dữ liệu của
tôi dành cho quá trình huấn luyện đúng
không? Tôi dùng toàn bộ dữ liệu để tôi h
liệu mô hình đúng không? Tôi không mất
một tí sample nào cho bộ va nhưng tôi
vẫn có bộ va để tôi đánh giá.
Được chưa? Thì đây cái này người ta gọi
đấy là cây f
cross
validation.
F tức là những cái lần gập đấy đúng
không? Cross là chéo. Function là xác
thực. Cross function là xác thực chéo.
Sao sách chéo đây này đây chéo này. Đấy
chéo này. Đấy chưa thế nên trong thực tế
người ta sẽ chỉ phân chia d thành bộ
trên bộ test thôi. Bộ truên người ta sẽ
không chia tiết thành bộ trên bộ va mà
sẽ dùng cái kef cation này đúng không?
Tức là gì? Tôi không có một bộ va cụ thể
nhưng tôi vẫn có cơ chế để tôi đánh giá
cái mô hình của tôi với bớ bộ dữ liệu
này. Được chưa? C focus version thì các
bạn thấy là rất nhiều những cái script
mà các bạn thấy là người ta dùng trong
machine diping ấy người ta sẽ không chia
làm ba bộ mà ta chỉ chia làm hai thôi.
Được chưa? Lý do vì sao thì đây tại vì
như này này được chưa?
Rồi. Ok. Ai có câu hỏi này không?
C question. Đây là một kỹ thuật rất là
phổ biến trong AI nhá.
Ờ dạ anh ơi. Vậy tức là ở đây là chỉ
chia ra hai bộ là trend với bộ train với
bộ test. Thì trong cái bộ trend đó thì
mình gọi là gì ta? Mình chia ra từng cái
bộ van validation nhỏ cho từng cái ca
khác nhau á anh.
>> Đúng rồi.
>> À
>> nhưng mà cái bộ vanilation đó giống như
là một cặp họp con của cái bộ trên đó.
Tức là bộ van nó nằm trong cái bộ nó nằm
trong đây này. Tôi làm bộ tôi có 4 phần
1 2 3 4 đúng không? Thì bộ va là một
phần
thôi.
>> À dạ rồiạ cảm ơn.
>> Ừ bình thường là tôi phải chia cứng ra
một cái bộ van. Nhưng mà chia cứng như
vậy thì lúc nào tôi cũng sẽ lãng phí một
cái lượng dữ liệu nhất định. Nó chả giúp
gì cho tối ưu mô hình cả. Thế nên tôi
mới làm thế này là gì? Tôi vẫn có cái cơ
chế để tôi đánh giá cái mô hình của tôi
nhưng tôi lại tối đa hóa dữ liệu dành
cho quá trình huấn luyện. Đúng.
Tại vì sao? Tại vì suy cho cùng ấy cái
mục đích của cái bộ va hay là bộ test ấy
là gì? Để tôi có một cái gì đấy để tôi
đánh giá mô hình thôi, đúng không? Cô
giáo cho các bạn làm mạch kể cho cuối kỳ
tại vì nó là cái thứ giúp đánh giá các
bạn đúng không? Thế thì bây giờ tôi tìm
ra một cái cơ chế khác thì tôi vẫn có
khả năng tôi đánh giá các bạn thì tôi sẽ
không cần không tôi sẽ không cần phải
làm bài kiểm tra cuối kỳ nữa được chưa?
Được chưa? Vẫn có cách để đánh giá mô
hình đúng không? vẫn đánh giá vẫn phe
làm sao bộ truyên bộ va không bao giờ
overlap với nhau đúng không? Bộ truyên
và bộ va không bao giờ overlap với nhau
đúng không? Trong cả bốn lần huấn luyện
này không có lần nào bộ chuyên bộ va nó
trùng lặp với nhau cả đúng không? Vẫn có
cái bộ va ở đâu đấy đúng không? Mà đến
cuối cùng tôi vẫn có thể dùng toàn bộ dữ
liệu tôi để tôi có lệ mô hình chưa ạ?
Ok cái này gọi là cây fold costion nhá.
Được chưa các bạn? Nếu các bạn hay lên
GitHub các bạn hay thật ra bây giờ có lẽ
các bạn sẽ ít hơn thường ngày xưa chưa
có E phát triển ấ mà phải lên ghép rất
là nhiều để tìm những cái report series
những cái project trên đấy các bạn thấy
là hầu hết khi mà người ta tự code ấ khi
mà người ta tự không phải tự code mà tự
phân chia rượu ấy thì người ta không bao
giờ người ta phân chia ra làm ba bộ rất
ít khi các bạn thấy người ta phân chia
ra làm ba bộ rất rất ít khi cái kỹ thuật
K4 C này nó sẽ đặc biệt hữu ích khi mà
có ít dữ liệu tại vì sao tại vì khi mà
tôi có càng ít dữ liệu ấy thì tôi sẽ lại
càng muốn dành nhiều dữ liệu để tôi dành
cho bộ tren các bạn có nhớ Nhớ là cái
hôm chúng ta học ở trên này mình nói các
bạn gì? Là cái tỉ lệ chia ấy thường là
có thể là 60 20 hoặc là 70 15 hoặc là 80
10 hoặ tí là 90 55. Thông thường cái quy
tắc là gì? Là nếu mà cái số lượng dữ
liệu nó càng ít ý thì cái tỉ lệ cho bộ
trên nó càng nhiều. Được chưa?
Rồi. Ok.
Magic để mình đánh giá ở mỗi lần fic
và cái số k nó cũng chả liên quan gì đến
nhau cả. Magic chỉ là magic [hắng giọng]
các bạn dùng các bạn dùng giả sử các bạn
dùng aquacy hay là ping hay là recol đi
thì cái việc quyết định trước sau nó
cũng chả khác gì nhau cả đúng không?
Quyết định trước sau nó có ảnh hưởng gì
đâu đúng không? Chọn giả sử chọn acion
rec one đi thì trước sau nó có nó có tác
động gì đâu đúng không? Nó đâu có ảnh
hưởng gì đế đâu. Đúng không?
Đúng không? Chọn trước sau có khác gì đâ
đâu đúng không? Tôi chọn xong tôi chọn
lại cũng được mà đúng không? Miễn là
chọn lại thì chọn lại tất cả đúng không?
Rồi chưa? Đây gọi là K0 cross các bạn sẽ
nghe cái này rất là nhiều. Các bạn sẽ
nghe rất rất là nhiều. Được chưa? Khi
nào các bạn đọc một cái đọc một cái
script Python về machining và deing ấ mà
các bạn thấy là chỉ có hai bộ thôi. Các
bạn hiểu chúng ta đang dùng này chưa?
Bây giờ quay lại script của mình được
chưa? Đấy là lý do vì sao mình chỉ làm
hai bộ thôi. Tại vì tí nữa mình sẽ dùng
KF Cation đó. Tí nữa mình sẽ dùng được
chưa? Để mình làm sao mình có thể tối đa
hóa dữ liệu trong bộ train.
Được chưa?
Rồi sau khi mình phân chia dữ liệu thành
bộ tr bộ test rồi mình làm gì tiếp giờ
các bạn nhỉ? Mình làm gì tiếp bây giờ?
Phân chia xong rồi làm gì tiếp bây giờ?
Phân chia rồi bộ trên rồi bộ test rồi
mình làm gì tiếp bây giờ
các bạn mình làm gì
làm gì bây giờ
ừ bây giờ đúng là lúc tiền xử lý rồi
này. Đúng bây giờ lúc tiền xử lý rồi.
Tiền xử lý nhá. Các bạn nhìn này, nhìn
lại ngắm nghía lại một tí cái bộ rượu
của mình nào. Ngắm nghía lại một tí nhá.
Ngắm nghĩa lại này. Bộ tr nhá. Đúng
không? Nhìn qua đi. Đây là xên đúng
không? Các bạn đã bỏ cái cột outcome đâ
rồi đây. Còn X này đúng không?
Cả tám cái feature này nó đều là feature
dạng số đúng không? Nó đều là dạng num
feature đúng không? Nên là về mặt kỹ
thuật là các bạn có thể các bạn dùng
chung một cái cách xử lý. Thì ví dụ các
bạn nhớ là hôm chúng ta học lý thuyết
này. Học lý thuyết nhá. Đâu ấy nhỉ? Đây
đúng không? Không học lý thuyết. Bạn
nhìn này. Chết rồi.
Đâu rồi ấy nhỉ?
À
đây chờ
chuyển trang nó hơi chậm một tí. Các bạn
chịu khó chơ một tí nhá.
À đây đúng không các bạn? Nhớ là xử lý
ra mình có nó có hai kiểu đúng không?
Một là người ta gọi là normalization
này. Tức các bạn phải xử lý cho cho từng
cột một đúng không các bạn? Chúng ta
đang muốn là gì? Đưa các cái feature về
những cái range nó giống nhau đúng
không? Một là normalization hay là
standardization này đúng không? Hai cách
như này các bạn nhớ lại mình nói là gì?
Cái cách đầu tiên này nó có cái ưu điểm
là dễ làm cách cái nhược điểm gì nó nhạy
cảm về outlayer đúng không? Cách thứ hai
nó ít nhạy cảm hơn. Được chưa? Ít
nó ít ừ nó ít nhạy cảm nó nó ít bị
sensitive với cả outlayer hơn đúng
không? Hai cách này trong sách cái ler
nó đều có cả nhá. Trong s nó đều có cả
cái này ấ trong sách scener nó gọi nó
gọi nó gọn có một class gọi là min max
scaler. Min max scaler đây nhá.
Min max scaler các bạn nhìn này. Đây
cách dùng đây các bạn nhìn này. Các bạn
bỏ không cần nhìn cái hàng thứ hai nhá.
Cái hàng thứ hai gần như chả bao giờ
dùng đâu. Nó chỉ dùng cái hàm thứ nhất
thôi các bạn thấy không? Đây này nhá. Tử
số là x trừ đi x min. Mẫu số là x max
trừ x min. Được chưa? Đấy cái này gọi là
min min min max scan. Được chưa? Cái thứ
hai người ta gọi là có thể còn cái mà
chúng ta nói là thì cái đấy m scaler nó
chính là cái normalization này. Còn cái
thứ hai là cái standardization này. Cái
này ấ thì trong s nó cũng có. Trong này
người ta gọi là standard scaler này. Giá
trị gốc ban đầu này trừ cho kỳ vọng này
chia cho độ đầy chuẩn này. Được chưa?
Các bạn dùng cái nào cũng được. Thông
thường với mình mình hay dùng cái ông
này hơn tại vì ông này nó ít bị nhạy cảm
với out layer hơn. Được chưa? Giống đấy
cực kỳ dễ luôn. Đầu tiên là khởi tạo
đây. Khởi tạo như thế này. Được chưa?
Hiện tại như thế này thì bây giờ mình sẽ
ví dụ mình mình mình muốn dùng nhá thì
mình sẽ phải import trước import nhá
trong cái lear này đúng không các bạn
nhìn nhá.
Vậy mình tắt AI chưa nhở? À tắt rồi tắt
rồi nhá. Nhìn nhá. Form
ơ tắt rồi đúng không? Tắt rồi nhưng mà
nó vẫn còn cái ngữ gợi ý. Scar này chấm
prepressing này. Đây nhá. Sus scaler
này. Được chưa? Sau ở dưới mình sẽ bắt
đầu mình sẽ khởi tạo khởi tạo này. Và
scaler bằng scaler nhá. như này đi đúng
không các bạn? Nhìn này,
cái standard scaler này nó là một cái nó
là một cái class đúng không? Nó là một
cái class đúng không? Mình đang tạo ra
một cái object từ một cái class. Object
mình tên là scalar và class là cái class
standard scalar này. Được chưa? Thế thì
các cái class này ấy nó sẽ có ba phương
thức nhá. Nó sẽ có rất nhiều phương thức
nhưng mà trong đó có ba phương thức mà
các bạn sẽ cần phải nhớ. Một là phương
thức tên là
pit.
một phương thức tên là transform
và một phương thức tên là
một phương thức tên là
chấm shift transform nó có ba phương
thức này.
Ba phương thức này nó khác nhau nào thì
mình cho các bạn một cái ví dụ nhá. Các
bạn cái ví dụ này các bạn tưởng tượng
này, các bạn tưởng tượng là
cái scaler này ấy à cả ba cái thì sẽ đều
phải đi với x ví dụ mình mình tạm đây
nhá. Xe này nhá. Các bạn tưởng tượng
nhá. Extrae là cái diệu đồ vào của bạn.
Được chưa?
Extrae là cái rượu đồ vào chúng ta. Thế
cái scaler này ấy, cái scaner này là cái
gì? Nó đóng vai trò là cái ông thợ may.
Ông thợ may sceller ông thợ may được
chưa? Xe là cái mảnh vải của bạn được
chưa? Nên bạn tưởng tượng nhá. Bây giờ
giả sử ví dụ là giả sử ví dụ là
trước tết đi đúng không? Trước tết các
bạn có một cái mảnh vải được chưa?
Trước giờ trước giờ là trước giờ là có
một cái các bạn các bạn có một cái mảnh
vải đúng không? Các bạn muốn muốn may áo
đúng không? Thì bây giờ các bạn đến tiệm
may các bạn đến tiệm may thì các bạn bảo
với anh chủ tiệm là anh ơi em muốn may
một cái áo mới. Em muốn may một cái áo
mới.
Thế các bạn mình hỏi này theo các bạn
bây giờ các bạn đến cái tiệm may các bạn
bảo các bạn muốn may cá mới các bạn có
cái mảnh vài như vậy thì việc đầu tiên
ông tiệm may ông ấy làm ông mình sẽ làm
cái gì các bạn?
Ông ấy làm cái gì các bạn?
Ông tợ may ông ấy sẽ làm cái gì?
Các bạn đến tiệm may các bạn mong cái
mành vải đến các bạn bảo tiệm may là anh
ơi anh may cho em một cái bộ báo mới thì
việc đầu tiên ông ông tượng may ông mới
làm và mới làm cái gì các bạn
hỏi á hỏi sai hỏi cái cỡ không phải hỏi
đâu người ta sẽ đo đúng rồi đo đúng
không ta sẽ đo đúng không hỏi khách có
biết đâu đúng không sẽ đo đúng không thì
các bạn nhìn này phúc fit này ấy nó
giống cái bước chúng ta đo đấy đo đo cái
gì các bạn nhìn đây Ví dụ ví dụ các bạn
muốn dùng cái ví dụ các bạn muốn đâu
rồi? Các bạn muốn dùng cái
này
thì nó sẽ đo xem là ở cái cột từng cái
cột một x min là bằng bao nhiêu, x max
là bằng bao nhiêu đúng không? Đo từng
cột một đúng không? Ví dụ các bạn áp
dụng cho tất cả các cột của bạn đúng
không thì mỗi một cột nó sẽ đo là x min
bao nhiêu, x max là bao nhiêu. Còn nếu
các bạn dùng cách này ta sẽ đo là kỳ
vọng của cái cột này là bao nhiêu, độ
lại chuẩn là bằng bao nhiêu. Đúng không?
Đây là cái bước đo nó là cái bước fit
này. Cái bước fit này nó cái bước fit
này dữ liệu của chúng ta chưa bị biến
đổi. Được chưa? Ở cái bước fit này dữ
liệu của chúng ta chưa bị biến đổi mà nó
mới chỉ được đo đạc thôi. Đo hoặc là
tính min, tính max hoặc là tính kỳ vọng
với đội chuẩn. Được chưa? Đây là bước mà
đo. Sau khi đo rồi, đo rồi thì ông thợ
may này ông này mới bắt đầu ông đấy mới
biến đổi cái mảnh vải thành cái bộ quần
áo đúng không? Muốn biến đổi thì phải có
số đo. Tức là nếu mà muốn transform thì
phải có fit. Fit là mới chỉ đo đạc thôi.
Transform là biến đổi đúng không? Sau
cái bước này dữ liệu nó mới được thực sự
nó thay đổi.
Nhớ chưa? Đo đạc trước biến đổi sau. Thế
còn nếu muốn bây giờ phải viết hai bước
thì bây giờ tôi viết chung một bước thì
tôi dùng fit transform. Fit transform
tức là gì? Tức là tôi sẽ
đo trước
may sau.
Được chưa? Đây là sự khác biệt. Fit này
transform và fit transform.
May xong rồi
ông thợ may thì ông lấy may cho một bộ
rồi đúng không? Hôm sau các bạn lại có
một mảnh vảy nữa các bạn đem đến đây các
bạn bảo anh ơi em lại có một cái mảnh
nữa anh may cho em.
Thì ở cái lần thứ hai này ông thợ may
ông ấy đã biết số đo của bạn rồi. Thì
lần thứ hai này ông ấy sẽ chỉ may thôi.
Ông ấy không có đo nữa. Được chưa? Thế
ông ấy sẽ chỉ may tức là ông ấy sẽ chỉ
tranform thôi. Ông ấy không không có fit
nữa. Thế thì ốp này vào bộ rượu chúng ta
thì quy tắc này các bạn này. Quy tắc là
gì? Là tất cả những cái phép biến đổi
tiền xử lý nhưế này ấy với bộ train bao
giờ cũng phải có fit transform.
Không fit thì không bao giờ transform
được. Được chưa? Nếu không fit ít nhất
một lần thì không bao giờ transform được
đúng không? Thì
với bộ trang thì sẽ phải fit transform.
Còn với bộ va hoặc là bộ test nếu có thì
chỉ có trform thôi. Các bạn hiểu này,
feit giống như kiểu là các bạn học, tran
form giống như kiểu là làm bài. Còn fit
transform là vừa học vừa làm bài. Thì có
phải là ngày thường các bạn đi học ấy
đúng không? Các bạn phải học kiến thức,
học lý thuyết đã. Sau các bạn chọn làm
những cái bài của cô đúng không? Tức là
gì? Hàng ngày là các bạn học và làm đúng
không? Học kiến thức rồi làm, học kiến
thức rồi ốp kiến thức đấy để làm đúng
không? lúc mà học lúc mà học hàng ngày ấ
là các bạn sẽ phải học rồi làm học rồi
làm học rồi làm nhưng đến lúc các bạn đi
thi cuối kỳ về thi tốt nghiệp chu phổ
thông ấy là các bạn chỉ có làm thôi lúc
thi là không có học hành gì nữa đúng mà
lúc thi không hành nữa nên là lúc thi là
chỉ có transform thôi được chưa nên là
bao giờ cũng thế fit transform với bộ
trange và transform với bộ test hoặc là
bộ va nếu có được chưa bộ va và bộ test
thì không bao giờ được fit cả tại vì fit
bộ va với bộ test có nghĩa là các bạn
huấn luyện lại cái mô hình với các bạn
các bạn là các Các bạn cho các bạn mà
fit với bộ test ấy, tức là các bạn cho
bộ test tham gia vào quá trình huấn
luyện rồi nó sẽ không còn chính xác nữa.
Được chưa? Bộ vai và bộ test là chỉ được
tranform thôi. Được chưa? Học là chỉ có
lúc hàng ngày học thôi, lúc thi là chỉ
có cái gì trong đầu lôi ra thôi, không
có học thêm cái gì mới cả. Được chưa?
Đấy là ý nghĩa của các cái hàm này, các
cái phương thức này. Fit này là chỉ có
đo, trang form là chỉ có biến đổi. Fit
tran form là vừa đo vừa biến đổi. Được
chưa? Với bộ train chúng ta sẽ
với bộ trúng sẽ fit transform. Còn với
bộ test á
chúng ta sẽ chỉ transform thôi.
Chúng ta sẽ chỉ transform thôi.
Được chưa? Nếu mình chưa từng fit bao
giờ ấy thì sẽ không bao giờ tranform
được. Các bạn nhìn nhá. Nếu này mình
chưa từng fit bao giờ mình chỉ tranform
thôi. Này các bạn chạy nhìn thử này.
Lỗi chưa? Lỗi này. This standard scalar
is not yet is not fitted yet đúng không?
Nó chưa fit bao giờ cả. Chưa fit bao giờ
thì không tran form được đúng không?
Không đo thì lấy cái gì mà không đo thì
lấy cái gì mà may đúng không? Fure
ch nhá.
Test nhá. Mình cho các bạn xem là lúc
trước với lúc sau trông như nào nhá.
Đây là lúc sau khi bến đổi nhá. Lúc lúc
trước đi. Lúc trước này. Lúc trước khi
biến đổi nhá. Nhìn này.
Đây X trang trông rất bình thường đúng
không? Hoàn toàn thân thể bình thường
không có vấn đề gì cả. Đây là bộ tren
lúc trước khi các bạn biến đổi đúng
không? Các bạn nhìn sau khi biến đổi
này.
Nhìn nhá.
Đây các bạn nhìn này. Đây chết rồi nhầm
ra y rồi. Xe đây. Sau khi biến đổi các
bạn nhìn này.
Được chưa?
Các cái cột bây giờ các cái giá trị hầu
hết nó rơi vào trong khoảng từ -3 cho
đến 3 cái tính chất của phân chuẩn. Được
chưa?
Đấy tác dụng của tiền xử lý này. Đó lúc
ban đầu có thể diện bạn mỗi ông nó một
giải giá trị với nhau. Có ông từ 0 đến
1, có ông từ 0 đến 100, ông từ 0 đến
1000. Nhưng mà sau khi bạn biến đổi xong
thì hầu hết mọi thứ nó đều từ -3/3 cả.
Được chưa?
Đây là tiền xử lý. Được chưa? Nhớ nhá.
Với bộ test là chỉ có trang form thôi.
Bộ va bộ test là chỉ có trang form thôi.
Còn bộ trên là cả fit cả trang form.
Được chưa?
Rồi đến đây có bắt nào có câu hỏi gì
không?
Đến đây có ai có thắc mắc gì không?
Any questions?
Có cái gì không clear không rõ ràng
không các bạn?
Tiếp nhá.
Thì bây giờ các bạn nhìn này, ở đây là
mình tiền xử lý sau khi mình đã phân
chia dữ liệu rồi. Được chưa? Thế bây giờ
nếu mình đổi đi, mình cho cái bước này
lên phía trước đi,
lên phía trước như này,
mình đổi cái bước tiền sử nhưế này mình
đổi trước khi mình phân chia thành bộ
trên bộ test thì mình sẽ chỉ làm cùng
với cái bộ x này thôi.
Theo các bạn mình đổi này có được không?
Đổi này có được không?
Đổi như này có được không các bạn?
Đổ này có được không?
Đổi này có được không?
Ảnh hưởng đến bộ test cụ thể lại gửi như
nào? Ảnh hưởng đến bộ test cụ thể người
như nào?
Đổi như này không được. Đúng là không
được thôi. Nhưng mà vì sao? À nó bị đúng
rồi. Dùng rất là chính xác. Người ta gọi
là data lckage là bị dò gì dữ liệu. Do
gì? Tại vì sao? Tại vì như này ấy có
nghĩa là gì? Có nghĩa là có những cái
sample của bộ va à của của bộ test ấy nó
được tham gia vào quá trình tính kỳ vọng
với độ chuẩn đúng không? Nguyên tắc của
bộ chuyên bộ va bộ test là gì? Là bộ va
và vào bộ test không được tham gia vào
quá trình huấn luyện dưới bất kỳ một
hình thức gì. Còn ở đây chúng ta làm thế
này tức là gì? Tức là quá trình chúng ta
đang tính kỳ vọng với đội chuẩn ấy là có
cả những cái sample của bộ test tham
tham gia rồi. Được chưa? Bộ test đúng
không? Các bạn không trong quá trình các
bạn học các bạn không được tiếp xúc với
cái đề thi dưới bất kỳ một cái hình hình
dạng nào không bất kỳ một cái hình hình
thức nào không được đúng không? Đây là
gì? Là trong quá trình chúng ta là bộ
test nó đã tham gia luôn vào quá trình
chúng ta tính kỳ vọng với đội chuẩn rồi
nó sẽ không còn chính xác nữa. Đó nên là
không bao giờ các bạn được phép tiền xử
lý trước khi các bạn phân chia dữ liệu
mà phải phân chia xong rồi có bộ chuyên
và test riêng rồi mình bắt đầu mình mới
phân chia được chưa?
Scan này. Rồi đây là mình tiền xử lý.
Đáng nhẽ bình thường với cái bộ rượu
khác nó phức tạp hơn nó có đủ cả loại
categorical nó là đủ các loại khác thì
các bạn sẽ phải mỗi một cột các bạn sẽ
phải xử lý khác nhau. Nhưng mà với cái
bộ này do là về mặt bản chất là tất cả
chúng đều là dự dạng số nên các bạn phải
dùng cách đúng không? Hoặc các bạn mà
không thích dùng Sus Scaler này các bạn
dùng các bạn dùng
sceller cũng được. Đây scalar các bạn
nhìn không? Cho tất cả nó đều trong
khoảng từ 0 đến 1 đây này. Nhìn nhá. Hay
ấm tất cả 0 đến 1 này. Tất cả 0 đến 1
không ôm nào nhỏ hơn 0 ông cháo ông nào
lớn hơn 1 cả. Được chưa? Đấy.
Thế ngoài hai ông này ra ấy với cái
standard scaler ấy thì nó còn một nó có
một cái phiên bản à premium hơn một tí.
Với
đâu nhỉ nhá? Với cái sceller này nó có
một cái phiên bản premium hơn một chút.
Nó là gì? gọi là robot scaler. Robot
scaler có nghĩa gì? Robot scaler có
nghĩa là nó giống nó giống y chang
standard scaler. Stand scalar các bạn
hiểu nhá. Ví dụ dữ liệu bạn như này đúng
không các bạn? Lấy tất cả dữ liệu các
bạn đây. Các bạn tính ra kỳ vọng cái đội
chuẩn. Nhưng mà với cái robot scaler này
nó sẽ làm gì? Nó sẽ chỉ lấy 50% rượu ở
giữa để nó tính kỳ bọ cái độ chuẩn thôi.
Tức là gì các bạn sắp xếp rượu bạn từ bé
đến lớn nhá. Đúng không các bạn? Có thể
đây là ờ median đúng không? Median này.
Đúng median này đúng không? First
quanti.
First quant đúng không? Thì 3 đây đúng
không? Thì bây giờ ấy thay vì khi mà
bình thường tôi dùng stand scalar tôi
tính kỳ vọng với đội chuẩn tôi dùng thảo
bộ dữ liệu ấy thì đây tôi chỉ dùng một
nửa ở giữa thôi.
Tôi phải dùng một nửa giữa thôi. Đấy bỏ
hết chỗ này đi. Bỏ hết chỗ này đi. Đấy
tôi dùng một nửa giữa này thôi. Tính kỳ
vọng tôi cũng chỉ tính ở giữa này thôi.
Tính đội chuẩn cũng chỉ tính ở giữa này
thôi. Cách này vì sao nó lại tốt hơn
status scaler? Tại vì là status scaler
ấy tức là tất nhiên là so với Mi Max
scaler thì nó ít bị ảnh hưởng về
outlayer hơn nhưng mà nó vẫn có khả năng
nó bị ảnh hưởng đúng không? Có thể là
outayer nó ở đây, outlayer nó ở đây thì
bây giờ khi mà tôi đã loại bỏ được 25% ở
cuối và 25% ở ở đầu đi ấ thì gần như là
cái việc mà outer nó nằm ở giữa này nó
rất là bé. Tức là gần như là tôi sẽ loại
bỏ hoàn toàn cái ảnh hưởng của đi. Thì
đây người ta gọi là robust scaler được
chưa? Robux Scaner tôi vẫn biến đổi toàn
bộ dữ liệu nhưng mà bây giờ tôi tính cái
statistic tôi tính thống kê à tôi tính
kiều các đội chuẩn tôi chỉ dùng cái đoạn
ở giữa này thôi được chưa
rồi được đây
có như mình bảo ví dụ cái trường hợp mà
cái outer là cái đối tượng các bạn muốn
tập trung ấy ví dụ các bạn muốn phát
hiện người bị bệnh đúng không muốn phân
loại người bệnh người bị bệnh hiểm nghèo
ví dụ bệnh ung thư với người thường
chẳng hạn thì rõ ràng là những cái chỉ
số của người bị ung thư kiểu gì nó cũng
sẽ khác biệt rất là nhiều so với người
thường đúng không thì dưới một góc nhìn
nào đấy người ung thư chính là người
chính là outer thìế bây giờ muốn sự mô
hình phát hiện người bị ung thư mà bây
giờ cứ ông nào ung thư lại bỏ hết đi rồi
thì còn gì để mà phát hiện nữa đúng
không?
Đấy.
Rồi
chết rồi.
Rồi tiền xỉ xong rồi làm gì nữa các bạn?
Mình tiền xỉ xong rồi này. Mình làm gì
tiếp bây giờ?
Mình tiền xỉ xong rồi mình làm gì tiếp
bây giờ?
Ừ chọn order ngày xưa mình đi học người
ta hay gọi là xây dựng mô hình nhưng mà
thật ra gọi từ xây dựng cũng không phản
đúng tại vì bây giờ mô hình người ta xây
dựng tích hợp sẵn b thư viện hết rồi
đúng không các bạn bây giờ học lý thuyết
là như vậy để các bạn biết để các bạn
lúc các bạn đi phỏng vấn và các bạn các
bạn biết là điểm mạnh điểm yếu của từ mô
hình nó cái gì thôi chứ còn lúc các bạn
đi làm thì thì nó chỉ gọi là chọn mô
hình thôi đúng không trong trong cyc nó
có đầy đủ tất cả những mô hình machining
cơ
và nâng cao và các bạn cần. Các bạn cần
mô hình nào các bạn gọi một phát là
xong. Được chưa?
Đây đây là bây giờ đây này. Đây ý là
chọn thuật toán đúng không? Chọn thuật
toán phí dữ liệu và cho thuật toán thì
chúng ta có mô hình đây là bây giờ đây
này. Chính là bây giờ đây này đúng
không? Đúng không? Gọi là chọn mô hình
mà thật thật thật ra cái mình chọn là
chọn thuật toán đúng không? Fit dữ liệu
và thuật toán thì chúng ta có mô hình
được chưa?
Thì chúng ta thọt thuật toán gì bây giờ?
Các bạn biết là vừa nãy chúng ta nói rồi
là chúng ta sẽ chọn mô hình những cái th
toán gọi là mô hình cho quen mồm gọi là
chọn mô hình phi tuyến đúng không? Mô
hình phi tuyến thì nhiều lắm. Mô hình
phi tuyến ví dụ các bạn dùng các bạn
dùng các bạn dùng à ví dụ như là support
v machine chẳng hạn đúng không? Thì các
bạn nhìn nhá.
Các bạn nhìn này.
Các bạn nhìn nhá.
Sai cái lân rồi. Ch đủ các chậ toán các
bạn cần đúng không? Ờ được. Logistic
version cũng được nhưng mà ở đây mình sẽ
không ở đây mình sẽ không thử ngay
logistic reation tại vì sao? Tại vì như
vậy chúng ta có nói là gì là cái bộ rượu
này ấ nó chẳng có cái feature nào có cái
hệ số tương quan lớn đến tit cả đúng
không? Dùng thì cũng được thôi nhưng mà
thông thường logistic question nó sẽ đây
ví dụ đi ví dụ mình muốn dùng nhá
logistic regression nhá skiller nhá ví
dụ mình muốn dùng đi đúng không dùng thì
cứ dùng thôi nhưng mà khả năng cao là nó
cũng sẽ không có tốt lắm đâu tại vì là
mình có cái feature nào có hệ số tương
quan lớn đâu đúng không đây dùng rất là
dễ thôi cái này đây mình import nhá
linear model này nhìn nhá
nào form it learn đây linear này à mình
phải dùng là logistic đúng không
logistic
logistic này được chưa? Mình cho ở dưới
mình cho model đây. Moder bằng
logistication này. Được chưa? Đây là
dòng các bạn khai báo mô hình đúng
không? Thật ra là các bạn khai báo thuật
toán thế nhưng mà thông thường người ta
hay gọi là mô hình đúng không? Thuật
toán phải đưa rượu vào thuật toán rồi
các bạn mới có mô hình đúng không? Đây
là dòng các bạn huấn luyện này. Các bạn
đưa input và các bạn đưa label vào đ
input để cho mình nó đưa dự đoán dự đoán
xanh cái label để các bạn ra được cái
lót của các thứ thứ đúng không? Đấy như
này thì xong cái dòng số 25 này là các
bạn xong quá trình khấn luyện mô hình
rồi. Đây xong dòng số 25 là xong quá
trình khó luyện rồi. Tất nhiên là nó
cũng chả in ra cái gì cả tại vì chúng ta
có in cái gì ra đâu đúng không? Chúng ta
có print prủng cái gì đâu đúng không?
Chúng ta chả có cái gì cả. Nhưng mà về
mặt bản chất là đây là xong rồi. Xong
rồi đúng không? À các bạn đọc rượu vào
này. Các bạn tách rượu ra các bạn tiền
xử lý rồi các bạn huấn luyện mô hình
xong hết rồi. Được chưa?
Thế bây giờ
nhiều lắm nhiều lắm. Đây các bạn nhìn
này nhìn nó có nhiều nữ đây. L model
đây. Còn trong dướ này có rất nhiều đây
đây được chưa? Line classifier này nhiều
lắm
này mình gửi nhá. Đây này.
Nhiều lắm. Được chưa?
Thế các bạn nhìn này. Các bạn nhìn này.
Đến cái bước này chúng ta huấn luyện
xong rồi. Theo các bạn sau khi các bạn
huấn luyện xong mô hình rồi, các bạn sẽ
làm gì tiếp?
Huấn luyện xong rồi thì tôi làm gì tiếp
bây giờ?
nhận xong rồi thì tôi làm gì tiếp bây
giờ
mình hết mô hình xong rồi theo các bạn
mình sẽ làm gì tiếp à đúng rồi test các
bạn nhìn chú ý nhá ở đây là mình vẫn
hoàn toàn chưa hề có sự xuất hiện của bộ
va nhá bộ va vẫn chưa hề xuất hiện nhá
mình vẫn chưa dùng cây f cross fation đâ
cây ph ở phần sau cơ đúng không ở đây
chúng ta vẫn chưa bộ va đúng không đúng
rồi test là gì tôi sẽ đem cái mô hình
này tôi đã huấn luyện xong rồi tôi sẽ
thử đem nó test với cái bộ x test này.
Đó các bạn nhìn này nó sẽ như này nhá. I
này px được chưa? Bằng model.px này. Đấy
tôi đem cái mình đã được huấn luyện rồi.
Tôi test với cái bộ test này ra cái này
rồi. Sau lại rồi mình làm gì tiếp
ra được y phí rồi làm gì tiếp.
Ừ đúng rồi. Phải phải phải phải phải đo
lường cái gì đấy đúng không? Đúng không?
Với bài toán phân loại chẳng hạn à các
bạn nhớ là cái bộ lúc mà chúng ta xem
lại cái report nhá. Các bạn nhìn cái cái
report này. Ờ cái bộ cái đâu rồi? Cái
outc nhá các bạn. Thì này đây hai class
đây. Các bạn thấy phân bố nó như nào?
Các bạn phân bố như nào? Đây là hai
class đây. Class số 0 có 500. Class số 1
có 268 các bạn. Các bạn thấy nó như nào?
Thấy như nào?
Lệch
thật thật thật ra đúng là về mặt đo
lường thì đúng là bộ này nó lệch thật.
Đúng là đo lường bộ này lệch thật. Thế
nhưng mà trong cái thế giới của Merching
ấy lệch như thế này nó vẫn còn là khá
đẹp.
Đúng là về mặt con số thì nó nó lệch
thật.
Nhưng với machine sao các bạn đi làm ấy
mà các bạn đã gặp được cái bộ này là các
bạn rất may mắn. Rất rất may mắn đúng
không? Đúng là nó có hơi hơi lạnh thật
nhưng nó không quá nhiều. Không quá
nhiều. Thông thường nhá. Thông thường
thì như này người ta
như này là đã có thể dùng accuracy rồi.
Như thế này là dùng accuracy được rồi.
Được chưa? Thông thường trong khái niệm
chúng ta thường là nếu mà cái tỉ lệ giữa
cái class lớn nhất với bé nhất ấy nó
dưới 10 thì người ta có thể gọi là
imbalance. Ok. Còn trên 10 lần thì có
thể gọi là highly imbalance. Nhưng này
khá là ok. Cái này các bạn thích các bạn
dùng ac
cũng ok không có vấn đề gì cả. Được
chưa?
Thế bây giờ giả sử mình muốn dùng
accuracy đi đúng không? Giả sử mình muốn
dùng accuracy đi được không? thì mình sẽ
phải so sánh giữa cái dự đoán của mô
hình với cái thực tế đúng không? Thì
trong cơn nó có cả một cái hệ sinh thái
về magic nhá. Sơn magic rất là nhiều rất
nhiều magic các bạn nhìn nhá. Tất nhiên
mình đang tập trung về magic cho bài
toán classification đây. Rất rất nhiều
các bạn nhỉ? Rất rất nhiều được chưa?
Aquac nhá. AUC nhá. Rồi dưới các bạn sẽ
có Rất có nhiều thứ này.
Đâu rồi precision này. Recall này đúng
không? RC AUC này lại có hay F1 score
này rất là nhiều đúng không? Rất rất là
nhiều. Cách dùng thì gần như là như
nhau. Đây là của bài toán classification
nhá. Hôm tới chúng ta đến cái project
thứ hai chúng ta sẽ dùng đến regression
được chưa? Nó thậm chí nó còn có cả cho
bài toán clustering và bài toán phân cụm
nữa. Bài toán unv nữa. Được chưa? Nhưng
mà chúng ta chúng ta tập trung vào cái
classification trước được chưa? Ví dụ
mình muốn dùng accuracy đi được chưa?
Thì các bạn chú ý này. Với tất cả những
cái magic dành cho bài toán học có giám
sát nhá. Thì trong sơn ấy các bạn sẽ đều
phải đưa vào i thực tế trước, y dự đoán
sau.
Chú ý là cái này nó đi theo từng
framework.
Cái khóa này chúng ta dùng skill các bạn
phải đưa vào y thực tế cho y sau. Nhưng
mà
nhưng mà sang khóa sau ấy bạn nào các
bạn học về khóa deinking học về Python
ấy nó lại ngược lại nó lại các bạn các
bạn dùng lot trong Python các bạn lại
phải đưa vào dự đoán trước thực tế sau.
Được chưa? Ừ. Có bạn nào các bạn muốn
hỏi gì à? Cứ hỏi đi.
Có bạn nào muốn hỏi gì à?
Đấy được chưa? Thì đây là cái magic dùng
thì dễ lắm. Dùng đây các bạn dùng đây
đây này. Dùng đây đúng hướng dẫn thôi.
Nhìn nhá. Form secar.mic import acquis
score nhá. Nhìn nhá. Rất là dễ luôn. For
thế nên mình bảo các bạn là cái khóa này
ấ khó nhất là sáu bảy cái buổi đầu tiên
là khó nhất. Còn từ thực hành nó cực kỳ
dễ luôn. Tại vì có cái gì đâu. Thư viện
nó làm hết rồi. Learn
chấm magriic
score nhá. Được chưa? Dưới mình bắt đầu
mình in ra này. Print nhá. Print này.
Score nhá. Đây này. Y này đúng không? Y
thực tế vào trước Y dự đoán vào sau.
Nhìn thử nhá. Nhìn này.
Nhìn này.
Kết quả đây này.
Các bạn thấy mô hình như nào? Kết quả
này khoảng à được bao nhiêu? Như 78% đi
đúng không? Aquac 78%.
Các bạn thấy nào?
Mình cũng không biết đâu. Mình đang hỏi
các bạn này. Mình đang hỏi các bạn này.
Mình mình cũng có có biết đâu. Mình
không biết. Mình cũng không biết.
Các bạn thấy nào?
Khả năng cao cái mô hình của mình nó
chính là baseline đấy. Ông khả năng cao
ví dụ nếu mà trước đây chưa có ông nào
ông nấy làm ra thì khả năng mô hình của
mình là mô hình baseline đấy nhá. Mình
cũng không biết đây là tốt hay không
đúng không? Mình chỉ biết được cái mô
hình của mình cứ khoảng 100 người dự
đoán nó dự đoán đúng 78 người nó tốt hay
không mình không biết đúng không? Muốn
biết nó tốt hay không ấy thì phải có một
cái expert của cái lĩnh vực đấy đúng
không? Phải có một cái expert để họ xem
là bình thường với con người dẫng như
thế dự đoán đúng đường này là ok hay
không. Còn chúng ta là người ngoại đạo
không hẳn là người ngoại đạo nhưng chúng
ta là một data scientist, chúng ta là
một machininger. Nhiệm vụ của chúng ta
là tạo ra một cái mô hình dự đoán càng
chính xác càng càng tốt. Còn tiêu chuẩn
của cái lĩnh vực đấy nó ở mức nào tôi
không có biết đúng không? Mình cũng chả
biết thế này có tốt hay không. Nếu mà
chỉ nhìn con số này đúng không? Phải có
một ông chuyên gia đ ngồi thì mình hỏi
là anh ơi về tình hình tiểu đường ở Việt
Nam mô hình của em như này nó có đúng
hay không? À nó có thế này có ok không?
Thì lúc ấy mình mới biết đúng không?
Đấ
ở đây thì như mình nói tại muốn biết nó
tốt hay không lại phải dựa vào cái
domain expert ta phải dựa vào đúng cái
lĩnh chuyên môn đấy phải có đúng chuyên
gia trong lĩnh vực đấy đúng không mà
chúng ta chúng ta sẽ không th chúng ta
là chuyên gia trong mọi lĩnh vực được th
nhiều chúng ta là gì chúng ta chỉ ra
chúng ta cố gắng cải thiện mô hình nó
càng chính xác về một cái hướng nào đấy
thì càng tốt đúng không còn việc là đánh
giá xem nó nó nó tốt hay không thì như
mình nói chúng ta sẽ cần phải có thêm
một chuyên gia nữa đúng không thế
đây là mình đang dùng một mô hình tuyên
tính đúng không? Về mặt kỹ thuật theo
theo lý thuyết thì trong cái bộ rượu này
chúng ta nên dùng mô hình phi tuyến tại
vì là chả có phiền nào có hệ số tương
quan lớn với tác ít cả đúng không? Nhưng
đấy là lý thuyết còn thực tế chúng ta
cũng không có biết đúng không? Nó giống
như kiểu giống như kiểu này ngày xưa các
bạn bảo hồi đi học ấy theo lý thuyết là
ông nào học càng nhiều thì sẽ điểm càng
cao nhưng mà tho thực tế không phải như
vậy. Có những ông nấy học ít điểm này
lại cao hơn đúng không? Thế nên là có
những cái thứ trong lý thuyết mà các bạn
thấy là trong machin nó đã nhẽ phải như
này nhưng mà khi mà các bạn áp dụng vào
các bạn thấy nó như thứ khác thì các bạn
cũng đừng ngạc nhiên tại vì nó luôn luôn
có một cái gác luôn luôn có một cái sự
khác biệt giữa giữa lý thuyết và thực tế
đúng không? Thì các bạn nhìn thử nhá.
Bây giờ mình sẽ thử thay đổi một cái mô
hình khác. Mình sẽ dùng support vector
machine.
Thế nhưng các bạn chú ý này, với hầu hết
các cái mô hình trong seon ấy nó sẽ luôn
luôn có hai phiên bản
nhá. Hầu hết với các cái mô hình trong
se nó sẽ có hai phiên bản. Một là phiên
bản dành cho bài toán phân loại và hai
là phiên bản dành cho bài toán hồi quy.
Các bạn nhìn nhá. Ờ
đây nhá. Support vetor machine ấy dành
cho bài toán phân loại ấ nó sẽ có cái
chữ là SVC này và một vài cái mô hình
nữa cái chữ C ở cuối là thể hiện là bài
toán classification đấy. Thế còn những
cái mô hình này cho bài toán hồi Q nó sẽ
có chữ cuối là chữ R. Chữ R đây này.
Reaction các bạn đ không SV đây
[hắng giọng] này. SVR này. NVR các bạn
đuôi cứ R đấy. Tức là gì? Hoặc là với
random forest đi. Random forest đi.
Random forest các bạn nhìn nhá. Random
forest nó cũng thế.
Đây nó sẽ có một cái phiên bản cho bài
toán classification và một cái cho bài
toán regression. Được chưa? Dưới này
cũng thế nó cứ một classif một
regression này. Thấy chưa?
Interface số này như thế nào cho nonch
hiểu? Rất rất dễ. Aquac bằng 77 coi như
78% nghĩa gì? Tức là cứ 100 dự đoán thì
dự án đúng 78. Cực kỳ dễ luôn. Acura là
cái magic mà dễ giải thích nhất trên đời
rồi đúng không? Cứ 100 dự đoán thì đúng
78 hết phim rất dễ. Đúng không? Rồi quay
lại đây. Được chưa? Quay lại đây. Đúng
con thấy không? Hầu hết các cái mô hình
trong sách cái ler nó sẽ luôn có hai
phiên bản một là cho classification và
hai là cho reaction. Được chưa? Tuy
nhiên cũng có những cái ngoại lệ. Ví dụ
là mô hình logistic regression thì nó sẽ
logistic re nó chỉ có đúng phiên bản
dành cho bài toán phân loại thôi đúng
không? Chúng ta sẽ không có cái gọi là ờ
đúng không? nó chỉ có một thôi hoặc là
linear relation nó cũng chỉ có một thôi.
Nó không có phiên bản cho bài toán phân
loại đúng không? Ông này là chỉ cho hồi
quy còn ông này là chỉ cho phân loại
thôi. Đấy.
Thế còn ví dụ như là đây các ví dụ đây
có phiên bản cho bài toán phân loại này,
hồi quy này đúng không? Giống nhau hết
chỉ khác nhau mỗi mỗi cái đuôi thôi.
Được chưa? Thế bây gi thử xem là support
vector machine
dùng cho những người này nó có tốt hơn
không hay là nó không tốt bằng đúng
không?
M
đây. S machine nó sẽ có hai phiên bản là
SVC là cho classification và SVR là cho
reaction. Được chưa? Thì mình lấy từ đây
nhá.
Đây cái lspm
SPM
import SPC này. Được chưa?
Kéo xuống đây thay mỗi mô hình vào đây
thôi.
H sin nhá. Đúng không? Nào
chào một tí nhá.
Giống kia nhở 7922 sẽ lại
logistic question
ơ sẽ giống nhau y hệt thế nhỉ?
Ơ
ờ sẽ giống nhau như thế nhỉ? Đổi thử mô
hình khác nhá. Mình đổi thử ví dụ sang a
random for đi. Random fres ở trong cái
này addsle này. Random fred đi cho khác
hẳn mô hình đi.
Các bạn nhìn này.
Các bạn nhìn này. Khác rồi này. Đúng
không? Về mặt lý thuyết. Về mặt lý
thuyết thì
Về mặt lý thuyết thì với cái bộ rượu này
đúng không? rượu mà chẳng cái feature
nào cái hệ số tương quan lớn với tit cả
thì đáng nhẽ là mô hình phi tuyến nó
phải tốt hơn đúng không? Nhưng mà các
bạn này khi thực nghiệm này mô hình phi
tuyến lại không tốt bằng này đúng không?
Nó có thể đến nó có thể đến từ nhiều lý
do. Một là có thể cách chúng ta tiền xử
lý nó chưa nó chưa hợp lý hoặc là hoặc
là do là cái bước chúng ta ngoài bước
tiền xử lý chúng ta có những cái bước ví
dụ là chúng ta điền rượu bị khuyết các
thứ nào nhưng mà bộ này lại không có
rượu bị khuyết đúng không? Hoặc chỉ đơn
giản là gì? Hoặc chỉ đơn giản là về mặt
lý thuyết thì nó tốt hơn nhưng mà trong
thực tế nó không tốt bằng thôi đúng
không? Nó giống yệt cái việc là gì? Là
hai người đi học thôi. Cái người học
thêm nhiều hơn nhưng mà đến lúc thi lại
không tốt bằng. Được chưa? Nhưng mà rất
may cho chúng ta là gì? là trong
machining ấy các cái thuật toán trong
machining đều những th toán rất là khá
là đơn giản quá trình huấn luyện nó rất
là nhanh nên các bạn có thể dễ dàng các
bạn test thử nhiều mô hình và các bạn
tìm ra thô hình là tốt nhất tức là gì
tức là khi mà các bạn đi trả phỏng vấn
ấy các bạn có thể trả lời là gì tức là
khi người ta sẽ hỏi các bạn là với cái
bộ rượu này tôi nên chọn cái mô hình nào
thì các bạn có thể phân tích là tôi nên
chọn mô hình A, mô hình B, mô hình C tại
vì là ờ đây là bộ rượu tuyến tính, đây
là bộ rượu phi tuyến cái lọ cái chai
đúng không? Ví dụ như vậy. Thế nhưng mà
đấy là lúc mà các bạn phải dựa vào tại
vì là bộ rượu tôi nó có những cái
feature có hệ số tương quan lớn với Tit
nên là tôi chọn mô hình tuyến tính còn
không tôi chọn mô hình phi tuyến. Ví dụ
như vậy đ lúc các bạn trả lể phỏng vấn.
Thế nhưng mà khi bạn đi làm khi bạn đã
có một chỗ ngồi yên vị trong trong công
ty rồi thì việc đơn giản là gì? Là các
bạn test thử tất cả thôi đúng không?
Trong cái lúc mà các bạn ngồi các bạn
suy luận xem là cái nào tốt hơn thì các
bạn cho anh em các bạn chạy mình chạy nó
đã xong xử rồi đúng không? Nó khác file
tuning là cái gì?
Huấn luyện mô hình là tôi dạy một cái mô
hình từ đầu từ mới tin chẳng phơ chẳng
có cái gì cả. Còn file tuning là cái gì?
File tuning là đã có một cái mô hình đã
được huấn luyện một lần rồi và giờ tôi
sẽ tận dụng cái mô hình đấy. Tôi sẽ huấn
luyện tiếp nó một chút cho một cái bộ
rượu mới của tôi. Cho nên khác biệt giữa
train model là các bạn dạy một đứa từ
lớp 0 à từ lớp 1 đến lớp đến lớp 10
chẳng hạn. Còn file th ấy là các bạn lấy
một cái đứa đã học hết lớp 10 rồi. Các
bạn dạy nó thêm một chút đến lớp 12. Đấy
là file tool được chưa?
Đang nói đến đâu nhở? Đây các bạn nói về
accuracy đúng không? Có nói về accuracy
chúng ta có thể nói về rất nhiều chúng
ta có thể nói về
rất nhiều cái magic khác nữa từ mình
quay lại với mô hình logistication nhá.
Logistic này lại
được chưa? Kết quả như này đ 77,9 đúng
không? Tức là trong trường này chúng ta
thấy là lối xị nó tốt hơn đúng không?
Thì bây giờ mình giả sử mình à đầu tiên
là nó là là nói về cái cái score đi đúng
không? Bây giờ nếu mình không nếu mà
muốn là ngoài acas mình quan tâm đ khác
nữa ví dụ là precision này
recion này đúng không? Reconnect one
nhá. Mình in ra đủ này. In ra đủ nhá.
Mình sẽ in ra nhiều mình phải có thêm
cái dòng dòng chữ nữa. ACC này
đây nhá.
nhá đúng không?
Precision này được chưa? Pr nhá
nhá được chưa? Score
tiếu à?
Format
này
rec này các bạn chú ý nhá. Khi các bạn
dùng pion rec với F1 ấ nó mặc định là nó
sẽ theo class số 1 là class positive
nhá. Cái bộ rượu các bạn cái label ấy nó
mà 0 với 1 chẳng hạn nó sẽ tự động nó sẽ
auto nó coi class số 1 class positive
nhá. Được chưa?
Rec score được chưa?
Score này được chưa?
Store nhá. Được chưa? Bốn cái này chạy
thử này
cách dùng như nhau đây các bạn nhìn này.
Ai là tổng nhá đây là cho class positive
là class số 1 là cái class thiểu số đấy
0,75 thô là cứ bốn ông thì tức là cứ cứ
cứ cứ cứ cứ dự đoán bốn ông bị bệnh thì
đúng ba ông đúng không? Rec là 0,5 ta gì
cứ trung bình cứ 100 người bị bệnh thì
tôi tìm ra được 55 người đúng không? F1
thì trung trung hòa giữa hai cái được
chưa? Đây là cái magic của mình đúng
không các bạn? đổi mô hình cũng tương tự
như vậy thôi. Quest này
for này
các bạn nhìn này.
Đ for nhá các bạn. Lần đầu mình chạy này
7532 này. Chạy tiếp lần nữa này.
7597.
Mỗi lần chạy mình lại thấy ra một một
kết quả khác nhau.
7464 à 7 7467. Trong khi
logistic version
77922 nhá. Đúng không?
77922 đúng không? Mô hình logistication
chạy lần nào ra đúng một kết quả y trang
nhau trong khi random fred mỗi lần chạy
ra một kết quả. Lý do là vì sao?
Lý do là vì sao?
Vì sao random forest
cứ mỗi lần chạy ra một kết quả khác nhau
trong khi logistic question lần nào cũng
ra đúng một cái kết quả như thế. Lý do
là vì sao?
Chỉ được lý do là vì sao các bạn?
Do là vì sao?
Logistication không có ý tố ngữ nhân.
Chính xác. Logistic regression không có
ý tố ngữ nhân. Đúng. Random fres thì làm
sao? Random fred ngẫu nhiên ở đâu?
Đúng là logistic reation không có yếu tố
ngẫu nhiên. Chính xác. Thế còn random fr
ngẫu nhiên ở đâu? Ừ random set đúng. Nó
có một cái gọi là run set thật. Nhưng mà
sao lại có cái random state này? Đúng.
Trong
random for đúng là có một cái thứ nó gọi
là random set thật đúng. Nhưng mà sao nó
lại có cái này? Sao linear nó không có à
sao logistic nó không có mà f lại có.
Ông này trong fest ngẫu nhiên ở đâu mà
ra?
Sao lại chạy hai lần thế nhỉ?
À đúng rồi. Boot shopping. Chính xác.
Boot shopping tức là lấy mẫu có hoàn lại
đấy đúng không? Cái lúc chúng ta lấy ra
những cái tập con để phấn luyện cách mô
hình con ấy đúng không?
Thế nên chúng ta muốn cố định thì các
bạn cho một cái số này số nào cũng được
miễn là cố định lại
đâ đây 766 này đ này đúng không chưa
đấy
được chưa
ch hoặc là chúng ta đổi những cái mô
hình khác đúng không chúng ta dùng cái
init stable cũng ok đúng không rất nhiều
thắng khác nhau
có một điểm các bạn nhìn này đến đây có
ai có câu hỏi gì không đến đây có bạn
nào có câu hỏi gì không
đến đây có cái gì Các bạn thấy là các
bạn chưa thắc mắc thì chưa rõ ràng
không?
Các bạn nhớ nhá. Tất cả những lý thuyết
mình bảo các bạn là gì? Là với bộ dữ
liệu phi ờ tuyến tính tôi phải dùng thế
này. Bộ dữ liệu phi tuyến thằ kia ấy.
Tất cả đấy nó chỉ là lý thuyết. Bao giờ
cũng thế. Và thực tế các bạn phải thử
đúng không? Và thực tế các bạn phải thử
hết nếu có thể đúng không? Tại vì có rất
có rất nhiều thứ nó không theo lý
thuyết. Có rất nhiều thứ trong thực tế
thực hành nó khác với lý thuyết. Được
chưa? Trong thực tế chúng ta phải thử.
Với machining chúng ta còn thử được. Bạn
nào họ lên cái khóa sau khóa deing deing
chúng ta sẽ không có cơ hội để thử. Tại
vì sao? Quá trình huấn luyện cái mô hình
ming nó chỉ khoảng không mấy giây là
xong. Deing nó có thể đến hàng ngày thì
các bạn không thể nào các bạn thử nhiều
option được. Nhưng với machin chúng ta
vẫn còn có thể làm được. Được chưa?
Có ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Rồi nếu không ai có câu hỏi gì thì các
bạn nghe kỹ nhá. Có một điểm đây các bạn
cần chú ý này nhá. Có một điểm các bạn
cần chú ý. Riêng cái điểm này các bạn
tin mình đi các cái chương trình học
trình khóa trên chưa các trường đại học
ấy mình tin là người ta thường người ta
sẽ bỏ qua cái điểm này thì vì đây là cái
điểm nó khá là nhỏ. Các bạn nhìn nhá.
Các bạn nhìn này. Cái chỗ này này.
Ở đây là chúng ta đang làm cái gì đây
các bạn? Ba cái dòng này chúng ta cụ thể
chúng ta đang làm cái gì đây? Chúng ta
đang làm gì nhỉ?
Chúng ta đang làm gì đây? Ba dòng này có
tác dụng gì?
Làm gì đây? Chúng ta đang đây gọi là
bước bước gì nhỉ?
Chuẩn hóa đúng không? Chuẩn hóa tiền xử
lý đúng không? Chuẩn hóa tiền xử lý. Các
bạn nhìn này. Cái bước chuẩn hóa này ấ
tiền xử lý chuẩn hóa này nhìn chung là
nó sẽ quan trọng cho hầu hết các cái thu
toán trong machine nhá. nó sẽ quan trọng
cho hầu hết các cái thuật toán trong
machining.
Tuy nhiên nhá, nghe kỹ này. Tuy nhiên có
một nhóm các cái thuật toán trong
machining mà thật ra là các bạn không
cần cái bước này. Có một số thật toán
trong machining mà các bạn không cần cái
bước này
là những thậ toán nào? là những thuật
toán dựa trên cây
trong machine. Các thuật toán dựa trên
cây là các toán mà các bạn bỏ cái bước
này đi cũng không sao.
Th toán dựa đến cây là cái gì? Bao gồm
gì? Decentry,
random forest.
Tại vì sao các cái thuật toán dự trên
cây các bạn lại không nhất thiết các bạn
cần phải cần chẩn toán dữ liệu này?
Tại vì với các thuật toán dữ liệu cây ấ
cách thức mà thuật toán tương tác với dữ
liệu nó khác hoàn toàn so với các cái tu
toán khác. Mình cho các bạn xem thử nhá.
Nhìn này.
Nhìn nhá.
Tương tác khác nhau tức là gì các bạn?
Nhìn này.
Nào các bạn nhìn này.
Đối với linear regression, thuật toán
tương tác với dữ liệu thông qua cái gì?
Đối với linear reaction thuật toán tương
tác với dữ liệu thông qua cái gì?
Thông qua cái gì? thuật toán tương tác
với dữ liệu đồ vào thông qua cái gì này?
Thông qua cái gì? Thông qua
thông qua cái gì? Với linear reation
đúng hàm số chọn số là tương là thông
qua thông qua phép cộng và phép nhân
đúng không? Thông qua cộng và nhân này
đúng chưa?
Polynomial relation thì chẳng qua cũng
là cộng với nhân đúng không? Lũy thừa
thì cũng là nhân mà ra mà đúng không?
Cộng với nhân đúng
ông này thì lại cũng cộng nhân được
chưa?
Ông này thì cũng cộng bao nhân. Ông này
thì nhân thôi. Ông này nhân không cộng.
Được chưa? Ờ
đâu rồi?
đâu ấy nhỉ?
Đúng không? Tất cả nãy giờ được cộng
nhân cây cây nestable đâu ấ nhỉ?
À trước trước
mach nhở
mình có đi nhanh quá nhỉ.
Machine đâu rồi nhỉ?
Đây đây đây này nhá.
Support v machine cũng là cộng và nhân
tại vì nó cũng ra cái đường cái đường
của chúng ta mà cũng cộng với nhân và
cây inable thì cũng vậy. Tại vì sao cây
nable nó phải dựa vào khoảng cách khoảng
cách là luôn căn bậc hai của x bình cộng
y bình cộng z bình đúng thì cũng là cộng
với nhân mà đúng không? Thế thì đối với
những cái thu toán như này chuẩn hóa là
rất quan trọng. Tại vì sao các bạn tưởng
tượng này ví dụ nhá ví dụ đi nói về cây
label đi. Nếu không chuẩn hóa, nếu ông
x1 mà giải giá trị từ 0 đến 1 ấy, ông x2
giải trị từ 0 đến 1000 ấy thì ông x2 nó
sẽ dominate, nó sẽ áp đảo ông x1 và ông
x1 thì gần như nó chả có cái vai vai trò
quái gì nữa. Vì sao? X2 nó lớn quá, cái
giải trị nó lớn quá đúng không? Nên là
với những cái thuật thuật toán nhà thuật
toán mà cái cách mà thuật toán tương tác
với dữ liệu thông qua phép cộng phép
phép nhân ấy thì cái việc chuẩn hóa là
rất quan trọng. Cũng giống như là cũng
giống như là đây này.
Đây này cũng giống như đây cũng thế
thôi. Các bạn có học vấn về kinh nghiệm
đi đúng không? Bây giờ học vấn mà tính
theo năm là từ 1 đến 10 đi. Kinh nghiệm
tính theo ngày là từ 0 đến 10.000 đi thì
lập tức là ông kinh nghiệm ông ấy sẽ
dominate ông học vấn. Ông học vấn gần
như chả có cái vai trò gì nữa. Tại vì
kinh nghiệm nó lớn quá mà đúng không?
Nên là phải chuẩn hóa. Đấy thì với những
thuận đoán này việc chuẩn hóa là vô cùng
quan trọng.
Thế nhưng với decent
nhìn nhá random fred thì cũng là là cái
là là cái nhiều của nhiều decision tre
đúng không? Thì mình chỉ nói decent tre
thôi là là các bạn tổng quát hóa được
fred đúng không các bạn? Decision tre
nào các bạn với decision tree thì thuật
toán tương tác với dữ liệu thông qua cái
gì?
Với decision tre thuật toán tương tác
với dữ liệu thông qua cái gì?
Thông qua cái gì? Không phải s không
phải thông qua cái gì? Tương tác với
diệu thông qua cái gì? À so sánh. Chính
xác nó tương tác thông qua so sánh.
Thông qua so sánh có nghĩa là gì? Các
bạn tưởng tượng này. Ví dụ nhá. Bây giờ
đi. Bây giờ điểm của các bạn từ 0 đến 10
thì bây giờ mình so sánh mình chia làm
hai mình chia làm hai bên thì mình lấy
cái mốc ở giữa là 5 chứ gì đúng không?
Nếu mà điểm các bạn từ 0 đến 10 mình sẽ
lấy cái mốc ở giữa là 5 để mình chia
trên 5 với dưới 5. Nếu mà điểm các bạn
là từ 0 đến 100 thì mình lấy cái mốc ở
giữa là 50. Thế vẫn chia được. Điểm các
bạn từ 0 đến 4 mình lấy cái mốc ở giữa
là 2. Điểm các bạn từ 0 đến 1 mình lấy
giữa là 0,5. Đúng không? Tức là gì? Mình
tương tác thự các phép so sánh. Phép so
sánh thì tôi chỉ lấy một cái ngưỡng tôi
so thôi. Nên là cái giải giá trị không
quan trọng. Giải gì tôi cũng chơi. Đúng
không? Các bạn tưởng tượng và xem đây
này.
Đúng không? Ví dụ nhá. Ví dụ soánh đi
đúng không? Ví dụ là đây này cái a
đây đúng không? - x1 chứ gì trị từ 0 đến
1 tôi lấy ngưỡng giữa là 0,5 tôi chia x2
từ 0 đến 100 tôi giữa 50 đúng không?
Kiểu gì tôi cũng chia được. Thế nên là
với decision free và tất cả những thập
toán khác dữ lên cây ấy thì cái việc
chuẩn hóa diệu dạng số là không cần
thiết. Tại vì suy cho cùng tôi cũng
không có cộng trừ nhân chia với nó. Tôi
sẽ không cộng với cái ông có giá trị là
100 mà tôi chỉ so sánh thôi đúng không?
Tôi sẽ không cộng với cả ông không không
cộng thừ nhân chia với ông số 1, số 2,
số 3 mà tôi chỉ so sánh thôi. Mà một khi
đoạn so sánh rồi thì giải giá trị là bao
nhiêu? Không quan trọng.
Ví dụ nhá. Ví dụ này các bạn nhìn này.
Nhìn nhá. Runf gì được chưa? Runfet nhá.
Nhìn này.
0 phẩy à 76623 chứ gì đúng không? Rf
nhá. 0,76623
nhớ nhá. Được chưa? Không phải sa 3 này.
Được chưa? Mình bỏ cho đi nhá.
Đúng không? Bỏ đi nhá. Nhìn này.
Mạnh không?
Chả khác gì nhau cả.
Thấy chưa? Tức là gì? Tức là với các cái
mô hình dựa dựa dựa trên cây ấy, các bạn
tìm xử lý thì cũng được nhưng mà nó cũng
chả có tác dụng gì cả. Được chưa? Các
bạn cho nó vào thì cũng được thôi, mất
thời gian thôi nhưng mà nó cũng chả ảnh
hưởng. Nó cũng chả ảnh hưởng thuê mình
thế giới, nó cũng không làm mô hình tốt
hơn, nó cũng chả là mô hình nó tồi đi.
Tại vì ngay từ đầu bản thân DC và Rom
Fed nó không nó không ke về độ lớn của
dữ liệu. Nó không bao giờ nó nhìn vào độ
lớn của dữ liệu rồi. Nó nhìn vào cái giá
trị chia thôi. Được chưa?
Còn nếu các bạn dùng mô hình khác nhá,
các bạn nhìn này. Các bạn nhìn này, các
bạn nhìn này. Dựa vào ví dụ mình dùng à
không biết bây giờ nó đã thay đổi trên
logistic ration nhá. Các bạn nhìn này
nhá. Ví dụ đây nhá.
À 0,77922 đúng không? Mình cho thử nhá.
Không biết là bây giờ nó đã đổi chưa
này.
Đọc cái lỗi gì đây?
Lỗi gì đó
sạy đây nhỉ? Quan
sa giống y hệt nhau nhỉ?
nhá.
Những cái bản những cái bản trước đây
của second là nó sẽ khác nhau các bạn
nhá. Mình không biết cái bản mới này nên
là cái bản cái bản trước của seconder là
nó sẽ khác nhau. Tức là với những cái mô
hình mà không phải dạng cây ấ mà các bạn
có tiền và các bạn không tiền xí là nó
sẽ kết quả khác nhau. Mà không biết xong
bản đâ không biết nó có thêm cái gì vào
không biết nữa.
Nhá các bạn nhá. Đại là như vậy tức là
gì? Tức là với các cái khi mà các bạn
dùng những cái mô hình ấy mà nếu các bạn
biết trước là các bạn dùng những cái mô
hình nó dự nó nó dựa trên cây ấy thì các
bạn có thể bỏ qua cái bước tiền xí dựng
số này tại vì nó cũng không có giúp cho
mình nó tốt hơn. Được chưa? Thế còn với
các kỹ thuật khác thì các bạn nên tiền
xử lý để đưa nó về chung một cái giải
giá trị. Thế nhưng mà ờ
các bạn sẽ nhìn thấy cái sự khác biệt rõ
hơn khi nào khi mà các bạn làm những cái
bài toán liên quan đến mô hình à các bài
toán mô hình hồi quy. Tại vì sao? Tại vì
các bạn tưởng tượng này nhá vì sao mà có
thể một trong số những lý do vì sao mà
các bạn đây các bạn thấy là bỏ cái bước
này đi nó vẫn thế. Tại vì như này. Tại
vì với logistic re các bạn sẽ chỉ đưa nó
về một trong hai ngưỡng thôi. 0 với 1
đúng không? Các bạn tưởng tượng là ví dụ
là các bạn có tiền xử lý không tiền xử
lý ấ thì có thể cái điểm dự đoán nó lệch
đi một chút. Thế nhưng mà đằng nào nó
cũng phải map về một đây này. Đằng nào
khi các bạn thấy là khi mà bạn dùng
logistic reaction ấy nó cũng sẽ phải map
về một trong hai giá trị. Thế các bạn có
thể tưởng tượng như này. Các bạn tưởng
tượng là khi mà các bạn đâu rồi nhá. Khi
mà các bạn
đâu rồi? Khi mà các bạn giả sử khi mà
các bạn có tiền xử lý đi đúng không? Thì
cái giá trị đầu ra nó là 0,87 đi. 0,87
trên 0,5 rồi nó sẽ cho là các số 1 đúng
không? Thì khi các bạn bỏ cái tiền sử nó
sẽ còn là 0,66 chẳng hạn. Nhưng mà 0,66
ấy nó vẫn trên 0,5 thì nó vẫn là cá số 1
đúng không? Thế là khi mà chúng ta dùng
logistic relation ấy thì nó sẽ có cái đó
là các bạn sẽ không nhìn rõ được cái sự
khác biệt đấy. Thế nhưng mà nếu các bạn
đây là mô hình tuyến tính à đây đây là
mô hình dành cho bài toán hồi quy mô
hình linear reation các bạn sẽ nhìn thấy
nó khác ngay tức là gì các bạn tiền xử
lý nó ra một cái một giá trị không tiền
xử lý ra một cái giá một cái giá trị
khác đúng không chưa biết là cái nào
thông thường thì tiền sử nó sẽ ra kết
quả nó tốt hơn đấy nhưng mà nhìn chung
là hay sẽ lệch lệch lệch nhau thế còn
với rand of fred ấy thì dù các bạn có
dùng bài toán hồi quy hay là các bạnùng
dùng bài toán phân loại thì nó sẽ đế
giới cản y trang nhau đế thế nên nếu mà
các bạn chưa biết trước là muốn dùng
muốn dùng cái mô hình nào thì các bạn có
thể các bạn bật vào các bạn để tiền xử
này. Tại vì sao? Tại vì là với cái mô
hình dự trên cây ấy thì có tiền xử hay
không thì kết bạn nó không khác gì nhau.
Thế thế nhưng mà nhớ là gì? Nhớ là cái
bước này thì với các cái mô hình như là
decent sh fet thì nó sẽ nhìn chung là nó
không có tác dụng đúng không? Tại vì
cách mà thô toán nó tương tác với dữ
liệu à tư toán tương tác với dữ liệu nó
không dựa trên các cái phép tính cộng
nhân thông thường nó dựa cho phép so
sánh. Được chưa? Đấy là một cái còn có
một cái nữa là gì? Các bạn nhìn này. Ở
đây là mình đang in ra những cái mic
khác nhau đúng không? Thế nhưng mà cái
này nó có cái nhược điểm là gì? Ví dụ
các bạn nhìn accuracy thì không nói làm
gì nhưng mà prion recol về f1 ấy nó chỉ
đánh giá cho class positive và class số
1 thôi đúng không? Bây giờ tôi muốn coi
class số 0 là class positive và tôi muốn
đánh giá những cái điểm này tôi đánh giá
như nào thì tôi lại phải tôi phải ngược
lại. Ví dụ các bạn nhá cái p score này
các bạn có thể chỉ ra là gì? Là ông nào
là ông positive mặc định là cá số 1 đúng
không? Các bạn có thể đổi là positive là
số 0 đi chẳng hạn các bạn này ví dụ như
nhá mình muốn đổi thành số 0 nhá đúng
không?
Post label này ví dụ bằng 0 nhá. Được
chưa? Mình đổi cho tất cả thì nó sẽ nó
sẽ coi ông số 0 là class là class
positive ngay. Thế nhưng mà nó hơi nó
hơi thủ công đúng không các bạn? Phải
ngồi các bạn ngồi điền lại này. Chên đấy
này đổi này. Được chưa? Cá số không là
cái đa số nên là điểm nó kiểu gì nó cũng
sẽ tốt hơn. Được chưa? Thế bây giờ ấy
mình mà muốn có một cái bức tranh tổng
quan về performance của mô hình dựa vào
prion recnect one dựa vào cả hai class
mà tôi không muốn phải in ra nhiều thứ
này thì tôi làm thế nào thì các bạn có
thể xóa hết cả chỗ này đi. Trong SER nó
có một cái người ta gọi là
classification report nhá.
Classificationification
report như này. Được chưa? Cái này nó
bao gồm tất cả những thứ mình vừa mới
show cho các bạn xem. Nhìn nhá. Green
này. Classification report này.
Đây nhá. Các bạn nhìn nhá.
Các bạn nhìn này. Đây cái này được gọi
là classification report. Nhìn từng thứ
một nhá. Các bạn có một cột là rec F1
thì dễ rồi. Support là cái gì? Support
là số lượng sample. Trong cái bộ test ấy
thì class số 0 các bạn có 100 sample,
class số 1 các bạn có 54. Được chưa? Đây
là prion với cả recol với fă của khi mà
chúng ta coi số 0 là positive. Đây mình
coi class số 1 là class positive. Được
chưa?
Aquasi tổng thì đây Aquasy thì thì là
bằng 0,8778. Được chưa? 154 là tổng số
sample này. Được chưa? Quan trọng là gì?
Quan trọng là hai cái dòng ở dưới này.
Hai cái dòng ở dưới đầu tiên là macro
average. Macro average là cái gì? Macro
average là trung bình không trọng số.
Trung bình không trọng số có nghĩa là
gì? Tức là cộng và chia đôi đây này.
0,79 +75 chia đôi 0,77 0,90 +56 chia đôi
0,73 đúng không? Cứ cộng vào chia đôi
thế này. Chung bình không động số tức là
gì? Ông có nhiều sample với ông có ít
sample là như nhau. Đóng góp bình đẳng
50 50. Đây là các bạn có hai class đây,
các bạn có ba bốn class cũng như vậy
đúng không? Nhiều sle đóng góp tương
đương nhau. Còn cái dưới này weed
average là trung bình có trọng số. Trung
bình có trọng số có nghĩa là gì? Ông nào
đóng góp nhiều à ông nào nhiều sle thì
đóng nhiều. Ông nào ít sle đóng ít. Đây
các bạn nhìn này nhá. 0,79 nhân 100 c
0,75 nhân 54 chia cho 154 thì được 0,78.
Tương tự này 0,9 x 100 c 0 phẩ 56 x 54
chia 154 thì ra được đâu rồi? Chia 0,78.
Đấy, trung bình có trọng số, trung bình
không trọng số. Khi nào hai ông này bằng
nhau các bạn? Khi nào hai ông này giống
nhau? Khi nào trung bình có trọng số và
trung bình không trọng số giống y hển
nhau.
Khi nào?
Khi nào trung bình không trọng số và
trung bình có trọng số giống y hệt nhau
như nào?
Tức là gì? Tức là gì? Tóm lại là gì? Tóm
lại là gì?
Tóm lại là gì? Khi nào chúng nó bằng
nhau? À khi nào ch giống y hiệt nhau cân
bằng. Đúng rồi. Khi bộ rượu cân bằng.
Chính xác đúng không? Khi bộ dữ liệu cân
bằng. Được chưa? Thông thường người ta
sẽ có xuống chúng ta nhìn cái ông dưới
hơn tại vì ông trên cào bằng nhau hết
rồi. Ông trên là ông đa với ông ông đa
số với ông thiểu số là cào bằng rồi.
Người ta sẽ nhìn vào cái dưới nhiều hơn.
Tất nhiên đây là có phải phụ tụ là cái
bài toán các bạn cần cái gì. Ví dụ các
bạn cần ví dụ các bạn cần cái pion của
cá số 1 các bạn nhìn vào đây. Đ ví dụ
các bạn cần xem mô hình là bắt được càng
nhiều người bệnh phải nhìn cái rec đúng
không? Ông nào là positive thì tại vì
không phải cứ số một là positive đâu. Số
1 nhiều khi chỉ người ta đánh số như thế
thôi. Có phải trong cái trường khác số 0
là cái class mà các bạn quan tâm cơ đúng
không? Thế các bạn phải xem là các bạn
cần nhìn vào cái gì. Còn cái âm dưới sẽ
bạn cho cái góc nhìn tổng quan đúng
không? Thế thì cái classification report
này nó là một cái nó nó là một cái phiên
bản tức là gì? Nó cho các bạn xem hết
mọi thông tin luôn cả accuracy cả
pression request one cho từng class một
đúng không? Đây là các bạn chỉ có hai
class thôi. Các bạn có 10 class nó cũng
có đủ 10 dòng luôn các bạn. Được chưa?
Thế thôi.
Được chưa?
Rồi. Ok. Có bạn nào không? Có.
Câu hỏi gì không? Chưa hết đâu các bạn
nhá. Chưa hết đâu nhá. Chưa hết đâu. Đây
mới chỉ là nửa già của cái của cái
project này thôi đúng không? Vẫn còn
nữa. Chưa tối ưu đúng không? Đây là mới
chỉ là chạy cho nó ra kết quả thôi. Chưa
hề tối ưu, chưa hề thử cái gì cả đúng
không? Đây chỉ chạy một lần một một lèo
thôi đúng không? Chưa tối ưu. Mai cho sẽ
tối ưu tiếp cái này. Được chưa? Trong
nội dung hôm nay có ai có câu hỏi gì
không?
Trong nội dung hôm nay quay có câu hỏi
gì không?
Được được chứ. Đây mình up ngay cho các
bạn. Đây các bạn chú ý này nhá. Sort
code mình sẽ luôn up các bạn. Nhưng mà
các bạn chú ý nhá. Mình vẫn recomment là
gì? Là lúc mà về ấ các bạn lần đầu các
bạn hãy cố gắng thử tự code theo ý hiểu
của mình. Xong rồi hãy nhìn source code
nhá. Các bạn hiểu code của mình à vẫn
chưa đủ khi nào các bạn tự mình code
được lúc đấy mới đặt yêu cầu. Tất nhiên
sau này chúng ta sẽ AI thôi. Rồi chúng
ta học chúng ta hiểu để sau này khi mà
AI nó gen code chúng ta hiểu nó gen cái
gì đấy nhá. Thế trong quá trình học các
bạn cố hôm sau tự cốt được. Mà đừng bật
AI đúng không? Đừng đừng bật anti
gravity, đừng bật close code, đừng đừng
bật bất kỳ một cái gì cả. Code tự code
thôi đúng không? Sau này khi mà các bạn
hiểu bản chất rồi các bạn dùng AI thoải
mái nhá. Được chưa? Mình sẽ up ngay cho
bạn cả script cả record luôn nhá. Được
chưa? sau hôm nay sau ngày mai, ngày mai
chúng ta sẽ làm nốt cái này và chúng ta
sẽ sang một phần của cái project thứ
hai. Xong mình cho các bạn một cái bài
tập về nhà sau để các bạn trong một tuần
nữa các bạn làm page tch thử nhá.
Nun value chúng ta sẽ xử lý ở ở cái
project thứ hai nhá. Project thứ hai
chúng ta sẽ nói về cái n value được
chưa?
Hyper tuning chính là ngày mai đấy. Ngày
mai khi chúng ta dùng K4 cross là chúng
ta sẽ kết hợp với hyp tuning đấy nhá.
Được chưa?
mình cứ personal like một model cho một
tas nào đó rồi lấy pure to thế là b
personal
cảm nhân hóa một mô hình trong một tas
nào đó là ta lấy pông thường là như thế
tức là gì các bạn hiểu như này nhảy nhá
mình lấy ví dụ một nói về mô hình ngôn
ngữ lớn đi được chưa các cái ông lớn như
là Open AI Google đi họ có rất nhiều dữ
liệu họ sẽ huấn luyện v những cái mô
hình tổng quát mô hình rất là to đấy các
cái mô hình như kiểu là GPT Gina ấy
người ta gọi đấy là foundation model.
Foundation model thế nó lại cái mô hình
rất là lớn. Bây giờ ấy tôi có một một
cái bộ rượu con tôi muốn làm sao tôi
điều chỉnh cái mô hình của tôi làm sao
nó rất là phù hợp với bộ rượu của tôi
thì tôi sẽ lấy những cái mô hình lớn
đấy. Những cái mô hình đã đ huấn luyện
với rất nhiều rượu rồi. Tôi huấn luyện
tiếp nó với cái bộ rượu con con của tôi
ấy. Đấy người ta gọi là F tool. Đấy là
cách để làm sao cho cộng đồng có thể
tiếp cận về AI khi mà cộng đồng chúng ta
là chúng ta đấy. Chúng ta không có nh
không có không có nhiều dữ liệu là gì?
Chúng ta sẽ không huấn luyện với cái mô
hình trắng tinh từ đầu mà chúng ta sẽ
dựa vào những cái mô hình đã được cái
ông lớn huấn luyện rồi để chúng ta huấn
luyện tiếp. Nhưng điều này nó chỉ đúng
với những cái mô hình trong deing và mô
hình ngôn ngữ lớn thôi. Và những cái mô
hình nó kích thước nó rất là lớn nó có
đến hàng chục triệu hàng tỷ hàng chục tỷ
tham số. Còn những cái mô hình này của
chúng ta là những cái mô hình mô hình
truyền thống nó chỉ có vài chục tham số
thôi là những hình chúng ta không từ đầu
được nhá. Nhưng cái mùi hình machine này
thì không ai fool cả tại vì nó bé quá nó
quá bé để mà phải f tool. Cái mồi này
các bạn có vài trăm sle các bạn không
lên được rồi. Thế nên là người ta sẽ
không file tun cái này. F tool là nói về
deep learning rồi sâu xa hơn là về
[âm nhạc] nhá.
Rồi ok. Có ai có câu hỏi này không? Học
xong rồi nay b chỉ có trả lời câu hỏi
thôi. Có ai có cái gì chưa clear không?
>> Em hỏi một câu đúng không Ừ được được
hỏi thoải mái.
>> Thế thầy bảo là các cái mô hình truyền
thống như này ấ thì thầy bảo hai khoảng
200 sample là chạy được rồi thầy.
>> Nó còn tức là nó còn tùy tức là nó còn
tùy được xem là cái bộ rượu này các bạn
nhá có bao nhiêu cột nữa. Ví dụ cái bộ
rượu này các bạn nó chỉ có khoảng hai ba
cột thôi. 200 sample là ok. Nhưng nếu
các bạn có khoảng 10 20 cột 200 nó là
ít.
Nó còn dự tức nó còn tượng tương quan
giữa số hang và số cột nữa. Giống như
kiểu này các bạn học 10 bài có thể là
đủ. Nếu các bạn chỉ học một dạng bài các
bạn chỉ học đạo hàm thôi. Các bạn làm 10
bài có thể đủ. Nhưng nếu các bạn vừa học
đạo hàm vừa tích phân, vừa lượng giác
vừa vừa vừa vừa vừa số phức mà các bạn
chỉ là 10 bài thì là quá ít. Thế nên là
các bạn học 10 bài lại là đủ hay là
thiếu ấy. Còn phụ dụ xem là các bạn học
bao nhiêu dạng bài khác nhau. Đấy tức là
cùng l số hàng đấy nhưng mà ít cột thì
nó thì nó là ok nhưng mà nhiều cột thì
nó thiếu.
Ờ model phải là một mô hình.
General model phải là một cái mô hình mà
tôi huấn luyện nó với một bộ dữ liệu
tổng quát. Được chưa? General là một cái
bộ rượu là một cái mô hình tôi huấn
luyện nó với một bộ rượu tổng quát, một
bộ rượu tương đối lớn, tương đối tổng
quát.
Ví dụ về ảnh đi. Bạn nào học cái khóa de
link lớp mình có một vài bạn đang học
song song về khóa deing đúng không?
Trong deing người ta sẽ huấn luyện với
mô hình ví dụ là cái bài toán phân loại
hình ảnh đi người ta sẽ huấn luyện nó về
một cái bộ gì là bộ image này. Một cái
bộ nó có khoảng 1 triu000 bức ảnh về
1000 class khác nhau thì bộ này là bộ
tương đối tổng quát.
đấy là đấy là cái đấy là cái điều kiện
của những cái mô hình được precha đấy.
Tức là gì? Nó phải nó phải có khả năng
tự nữ tổng quát rồi thì sau này người ta
mới lấy nó về để người ta file tun nó
với những bộ rượu con con. Đấy chứ còn
cái bước cái bước tổng quát này là phải
huấn luyện với rất nhiều dữ liệu. Nó rất
tổng quát. Còn nếu có ít dữ liệu hoặc dữ
liệu chỉ về một cái specific topic gì
đấy thôi thì nó sẽ người ta sẽ không làm
như thế. Ta sẽ không làm như thế nhá.
Đúng là như vậy. Làm như vậy nếu mà mình
lấy một cái mô hình đã được huấn luyện
với một cái bộ về chó mèo mà mình lại
pha thun ch ô tô ấy thì giống như kiểu
là các bạn lấy một thằng học chuyên pháp
để các bạn bắt nó đi học tiếng Nhật
chẳng hạn thì cái việc nó học chuyên
pháp nó chả chả có tác dụng gì cả đ ha
dữ liệu có hàng triệu bản ghi có thể lọc
bớt ờ có thông thường là có tô cho lọc
bớt không phải lọc bớt không phải là do
nó nhiều quá mà lọc bớt để tránh có
những cái rượu dư thừa không cần thiết
được chưa chứ còn có nhiều rượu là tốt
với dat có nhiều rượu luôn là tốt vài
triệu thì ta cũng không phải quá lớn chỉ
là tôi muốn lọc xem là có cái gì nó dư
thừa nó duplicate nó làm sao cái lọ cái
chai có nun value thôi thì tôi lọc bất
đi thôi thế chứ còn vài triệu thì là ok
bắt đầu có hoi gì nữa không
nhá qua có thắc mắc gì các bạn cứ hỏi
mình trên Zalo nhá hoặc là mai hỏi cũng
được hoặc là các bạn hỏi trên Zalo các
Các bạn mà ngại hỏi ngay trên group lớp
thì các bạn nếu mà các bạn hỏi trên
group lớp là tốt nhất tại vì mình trả
lời cho các bạn là các bạn khác cũng
cũng nhìn thấy. Còn không các bạn thấy
là nếu mà nó riêng tư nó về một cái
project của riêng các bạn các bạn hỏi
mình inbox cũng được nhá.
Ok
rồi. Ok cảm ơn mọi người nha. Cảm ơn mọi
người nha. Mai mai vẫn học giờ cũ nhá.
Hôm nay chỉ có mình hơi để tí mai vẫn
học giờ cũ bình thường 6:00 tối nhá. Ok.